Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Wenn das so weitergeht mit der Nachrichtenlage, dann sage ich einfach nur noch Oxy.
Weiß ich nicht, ich sage einfach Oxy.
Okay.
Und wenn ihr Oxy hört, dann wisst ihr, es ist wieder eine neue Folge von Logbuch Netzpolitik verfügbar in ihrem mobilen Abspielgerät. Mhm.
Buch.
Ganz normal äh ganz äh ganz modern.
Modern, normal, modern ist ja auch irgendwie normal für mich, zumindest. Jetzt sag endlich mal was, bevor ich mich hier noch um Kopf und Kragen rede.
Was ja, was er auch modern ist, ist ja äh überverbieten, ne, Uber verbieten. Wir hatten ja in der letzten Sendung noch kurz darüber gesprochen. Äh Franka ist da jetzt hat jetzt auch Uber Pop ist jetzt vorbei in Frankreich, ne?
Ist jetzt nicht mehr.
Nee, nee, nee. Ich wollte aber noch kurz was zu sagen, was ich in letzter Woche kurz eigentlich ganz vergessen hatte. Denn was äh ja auch dadurch entsteht, sind ja so, dass die Leute das ja,
dieses Mal Amateurhafte auch mal die Wohnung verbieten,
Total äh so zu ihrem Geschäftsmodell und machen uns so professionalisieren, ne. Also irgendwie.
Ähm dann quasi Gastwirte werden.
Ja, wenn nichts wird.
Dass es dabei Airbnb so und bei bei Uber werden die Leute halt äh äh Chauffeure und das ist halt so diese diese,
Professionelle, die die Professionalisier,
der Amateure ist das nämlich. Und das ist ganz schlecht für die Dienstleistungsgesellschaft.
Professionalisierung des Präkariats.
Ich wollte das Ganze nur noch mal so ein bisschen ähm äh irgendwie politisch fundierter äh äh klingen lassen, ne.
Meinst du, dass das jetzt auch gelungen?
Weiß ich nicht. Mal gucken. Ich hoffe, dass also ich hoffe natürlich, dass sich unsere Hörerinnen mit sowas nicht beeindrucken kann.
Ja, das Wort Professionalisierung ist ja ohnehin so ein bisschen überholt, nicht? Also das.
Ich weiß ja nicht so recht, aber in gewisser Hinsicht bedeutet Professionalisierung ja eigentlich nur äh, dass du das als Beruf machst sozusagen zum Zwecke des Geldverdienst.
Ausbeutung.
Ja und und und Amateur, was sozusagen immer immer beinhaltet, das ist,
ähm dass man das nicht wegen des Geldes macht. Ja das hat so eine Liebeskonutation im Sinne von, das macht man halt gerne, aber ich würde mal unterstellen, so unsere Generation oder zumindest so so eine gewisse ähm.
Gruppe von Menschen, die vor allem auch durch das Internet äh gelernt äh hat,
da so einen Zwischenweg zu finden, nämlich Dinge zu tun, die man gerne macht, aber damit auch sehr wohl Geld zu verdienen, die lässt sich damit irgendwie sowieso nicht mehr so richtig beschreiben.
Und deswegen finde ich, kommt das Ganze so ein bisschen durcheinander und dann ist halt auch immer so diese Aussagen, aha, man ist ja jetzt Profi, klingt ja immer gut, ne? Aber eigentlich heißt es nur so, na ja, man nimmt halt jetzt Geld dafür.
Und das geht dann halt mit dieser ganzen nochmal von hinten nochmal durcheinander und sagt gar nichts mehr aus.
Ich liebe es, Gäste zu haben. Ich mache das jetzt professionell.
Ich habe so gern Besuch. Ich mache das jetzt professionell.
Ja, aber mir ist irgendwie auch täglich kommt jemand rein, dann geht wieder raus, die Nachbarn wundern sich auch schon. Hm.
Frankreich war ja das war jetzt gar nicht so wirklich zum Thema gemacht, aber Frankreich war ja auch nochmal also war ja
vor zwei Wochen oder was in den äh hatten wir das glaube ich auch als Thema, dass ihr so auf Wiki Leaks äh gelandet sind mit
der Überwachung, die ihn aus den USA widerfahren ist, ne? Da haben wir noch äh unsere französische Präsidentschaftskunde hier äh vorgestellt und gezeigt, dass wir wissen, dass dass wir zumindest die letzten drei äh französischen Präsidenten kennen
und äh jetzt äh
sieht man Frankreich macht selber auch ordentlich Internet Überwachung seit zweitausendacht schön mit den Unterseekabeln, Abhörstützpunkte in Marseille, Marsch und zur Valerie und Co.
Also Süden, Westen, Norden und schön in
traut der Zusammenarbeit mit dem ähm und wir dieses Programm bis zweitausendneunzehn auch noch weiter ausbauen. Also wenn wir gestern einen zu revolutionieren, wenn wir gestern, sage ich schon, wenn wir
in der letzten Sendung ein zu revolutionären Eindruck Frankreichs vermittelt haben, dann wurde der jetzt dadurch ähm professionalisiert.
Ja, also überhaupt ähm zeichnet sich ein zunehmenden Maße ab, dass eigentlich sowieso alle die ganze Zeit
eigentlich schon immer und sie sagen deshalb so wenig, weil.
Der erste, der auspackt wird erschossen. Habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck und ähm ja, dieser Eindruck verfestigt sich auch durch.
Nachrichtenereignisse.
Ja, da gibt's eine eine sehr schöne
Eigentlich eine sehr brisante Geschichte, eine sehr schöne Geschichte, die ähm der äh Spiegel in seiner aktuellen Ausgabe auch äh schildert, ist das überhaupt noch die aktuelle, ja, müsste noch aktuell sein?
Und zwar, sie handelt von einem Spaziergang. Eine schöne Geschichte, sie handelt von einem Spaziergang. Günther, Heiß, nämlich der Leiter der Abteilung sechs, die für die geheim die Abteilung sechs des Bundeskanzleramtes, die für die Geheimdienste,
zuständig ist, wurde freundlich aufgefordert, von dem CIA Resident in Berlin. Er möge sich doch mit ihm auf einen kleinen,
Spaziergang treffen, nicht im Büro, nicht mit irgendeinem Protokoll, sondern so einen kleinen Spaziergang in Berlin
offiziell war der natürlich Vertreter der Vereinigten Staaten am Brandenburger Tor als Botschaftsrat dieser CIA Mitarbeiter inoffiziell war aber natürlich von der CIA,
und äh ging dann äh einen kleinen Spaziergang mit dem Herrn Günther und sagte tja ihr habt da im,
Kanzleramt einen hochrangigen Mitarbeiter, der hält enge Kontakte zur zu Journalisten und es scheint uns, dass der dabei durchaus dienstliche Sachen ausplaudert.
Vor allem gegenüber dem Spiegel und es handelt sich bei dieser Person um Hans-Josef.
Erzählt also so der CIA-Mann, dem Günther Heiß bei einem Spaziergang.
Hast du jetzt schon erwähnt, was der Günther Hals für eine Rolle äh.
Leiter der Abteilung sechs. Guck mal, Tim, du hast überhaupt nichts zur Leiter der Abteilung sechs, nämlich der Geheimdienstkoordinator im Bundeskanzleramt.
Genau. Aber man nennt das nur Abteilung sechs. Weil sonst wäre das ja dann auch schon wieder viel zu oft äh auffällig.
Sind sowieso durchnummeriert, die die es gibt auch eine Abteilung eins.
Und was sie sich, glaube ich, leider gespart haben, ist, was ich ja super geil finde, das wäre bei meiner Regierung so, ne. Auf jeden Fall in jeder Behörde fortlaufend nummerierte äh Abteilung, wo immer eine fehlt.
Weißt du so.
Abteilung fünf. Es gibt keine Abteilung fünf.
Sie aber im Kanzler, den Humor haben Sie im Kanzleramt nicht, eh?
Okay, so in dieser ähm Hans-Josef war eben der stellvertretende Leiter der Abteilung sechs und in dieser Funktion ganz offiziell mit Pressekontakten betraut.
Und er wurde dann ohne Angabe von Gründen ins Archiv versetzt.
Jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, woher weiß denn die CIA.
Und was der Herr Vorbeck in seiner Aufgabe der Kommunikation mit Medien, den denn zu viel oder zu wenig erzählt hat.
Könnte natürlich sein, dass die äh US-Geheimdienste, die Journalisten beim Spiegel abgehört haben.
Sie könnte aber natürlich genauso gut sein, dass sie die den Vorberg abgehört haben.
Oder beide.
Oder beide oder sowieso alle. Gab ja auch mal die Behauptung, die würden einfach alle abhören. Vielleicht ist da ja doch was dran. So, dann.
Aber wann denn immer oder was? Überall oder wie?
Das ist ja irre. Alle immer überall, unglaublich. Nein, das.
Vorstellen auch nicht.
Nee, so kommen wir gleich auch noch mal zu, denn so und jetzt, ne, dann ist halt die Frage.
Wie geht denn jetzt die Bundesregierung damit um, wenn der wenn sie quasi auf einen Leck an ein angebliches Leck in den eigenen Reihen von einem Bündnispartner hingewiesen wird,
und sie haben halt, wie gesagt, den guten Mann versetzt und damit hatte es sich das.
Hatte sich. Man hätte natürlich auch sagen können, alle seid ihr wahnsinnig ähm ihr hört uns oder unsere äh uns oder unsere äh ehemaligen Nachrichtenmagazine ab.
Hätte man auch sagen können, hat man aber nicht.
Deswegen hat der Spiegel äh dann am Freitag bei der Bundesanwaltschaft können wir den Bundesanwaltschaft.
Bundesprüfein war.
Des Verdachts wegen des Verdachts der geheimdienstlichen Agententätigkeit und der Verletzung des Fernmeldegeheimnisses Anzeige erstattet. Ähm,
Ich bin Mike äh gespannt, was äh was was sie da für eine Antwort drauf bekommen. Wir ähm.
Der CCC hat übrigens auch eine Antwort zu seiner äh Strafanzeige bekommen. Das haben wir noch gar nicht veröffentlicht.
Nee, welcher äh welcher Strafanzeige? Achso.
Gegen die Bundesregierung und so wegen äh und und die ganzen Geheimdienste und alle,
da äh haben wir auch eine Anzeige äh da vor langer Zeit ist ja jetzt auch schon wieder ein paar Monate her und da haben wir auch mehrmals nachgelegt und immer wieder nachgefragt. Da gab's jetzt eine Antwort, ich glaube, das kann ich mal, kann ich ja mal an dieser Stelle erzählen.
Die Antwort lautete,
Wir sind die ihrer ihrer Anzeige nachgegangen, dass Angela Merkels Handy abgehört worden wäre und mussten leider feststellen und dann haben wir genau diese Begründung bekommen, warum das Ermittlungsverfahren wegen dem Abhören von Angela Merkels Handy eingestellt wird.
Ja, also diese Begründung haben wir auch mit der Post bekommen. Der Gag ist nur, das war nicht.
Inhalt unserer Anzeige. Also das Abhören von Merkels Handy war nicht etwas, was wir in dieser Anzeige nennenswert benannt haben, sondern Angela Merkel war.
Objekt der Anzeige. Also wir haben ja,
angezeigt und nicht jemanden, der Sie abhört, beziehungsweise zumindest nicht deswegen. Ja,
Es war ein bisschen war ein bisschen, also ich habe das so mehrmals gelesen, hat so gedacht, ah okay, müssen wir hm, dann irgendwie so hatten wir das überhaupt erwähnt, so. Es gab irgendwie so eine Randnotiz so, ja und außerdem hören die auch die Kanzlerin ab, aber es war nirgendwo
erwähnt, dass wir jetzt irgendwie wegen des Merkel-Handys irgendwie irgendjemand anzeigen. Vor allem würde man deshalb ja nicht Angela Merkel anzeigen.
Also bin ich mal gespannt, was für eine witzige Antwort der Spiegel darauf jetzt erhalten wird und.
Der Sprecher des nationalen Sicherheitsrats der USA wollte das nicht kommentieren hat aber versichert dass normale Bürger
die unsere nationale Sicherheit nicht gefährden, nicht ausspioniert würden. So, aber natürlich ist ein Regierungsmitarbeiter kein normaler Bürger.
Ja, die Frage ist, wie wie viel.
Journalisten.
Wie viele Bürger werden also wie viele Bürger bleiben da eigentlich übrig, wenn sie die rausnehmen, die für sie nicht potenziell gefährlich sind.
Nicht viele.
Sie selber, obwohl die hören sich ja auch gegenseitig ab. Ja. Aber ich finde das natürlich schon krass. Also ich meine, dass das äh.
Was muss das für ein für ein schauriges Gefühl sein, ne, wenn dir auf einmal so ein CIA-Mitarbeiter, du bist irgendwie Geheimdienstkoordinator und dann kommst du der CIA Mitarbeiter zu dir und sagt, übrigens.
Der redet zu viel.
Also, klingt ja für mich jetzt nicht wie etwas, was da selten stattfindet, mal ehrlich.
Ja, aber das ist das ist richtig, aber das heißt, dass dass sie seit seit spätestens, man sagt ja immer spätestens, seit spätestens diesem Sommer zweitausendelf wissen.
Dass sie von den.
Von diesem Geheimdienst überwacht werden oder noch schlimmer, es dulden, dass dieser Geheimdienst äh deutsche äh Medien überwacht, deutsche Journalisten überwacht,
und offenbar noch nicht einmal davor zurückschrecken, quasi von den Erkenntnissen dieser dieser Überwachung,
in ihrem Sinne, in irgendeiner Form äh zu ähm zu profitieren
Ja oder an diesen Erkenntnissen zu partizipieren. Und das heißt ja letztendlich, dass sie, dass sie den, die, die Verletzung der, äh, der Gesetze Deutschlands durch die USA gutheißen.
Ja, ich meine, machen wir uns nichts vor. Äh, ich denke, dass dass jede Bundesregierung sehr wohl äh wissen muss, dass das einfach seit äh Beginn der Bundesrepublik so ist.
Die richtige Reaktion wäre gewesen zu dem vorweg zu gehen und zu sagen, ey äh Schnauze und hier hast du ein verschlüsseltes Telefon.
Spiegel, die sollen sich auch eins besorgen. Aber das tun sie ja nicht, ne, weil sie die, weil sie die eben nicht äh nicht respektieren, die Pressefreiheit. Weil sie sich.
Benutzen Sie einfach gar keine äh verschlüsselten Telefone. Also ich meine.
Nee, die kann man ja auch nicht benutzen, die verschlüsselten Telefone, die die haben.
Nee, aber die wir benutzen sie wahrscheinlich schon deshalb nicht, damit sie sich gegenüber den Amerikanern nicht verdächtig machen.
Genau, genau so. Was sollen die Amis denken.
Na ja, eben, also ich meine, wenn wir jetzt alle anfangen zu verschlüsseln, dann denken die am Ende noch, wir haben was zu verbergen.
Nee, nee, genau, nachher bombardieren die uns. Die haben mir angefangen, Alter.
Wenn wenn die nicht fortlaufend von uns in Kenntnis gesetzt werden, was wir wirklich vorhaben, dann kommen die mit irgendeiner Theorie auf und dann stehen wir da.
Und ruck zuck du weißt wie Trigger happy die sind. Ja okay, das kann man so aussehen, ja. Ja.
So
Pofalla war dann im im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss. Das war ja also ohne Witz, ja, ich meine, den.
Bin da auch mit mir selber gar nicht so im Klaren. Hätte ich es mental verkraftet.
Pofalla im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss live. Ja, geht ja nicht anders, kann man ja nur live mir anzutun.
Andre hat's getan, Andre Meister hat's getan.
Der ist ja auch komplett schmerzbefreit. Also was das betrifft, ja auf.
Wobei ich ja, also es gibt ja Gerüchte, dass der andere da die Schmerzverlagerungsmethode anwendet, ne. Also der haut sich die ganze Zeit mit einem Hammer auf den linken Daumen, damit's im Kopf nicht mehr so weh tut. Kennst du?
Der weint nachts im Bett. Na ja, klar.
Ja, müssen wir aufpassen, dass der uns über der Sache nicht irgendwie noch durchdreht. Ähm.
Smerzen im Untersuchungsausschuss.
Also Pofalla hat er eine, hat er ein ein Auftritt abgeliefert, der an Arroganz,
nicht zu überbieten war und ich weiß nicht, ob ich es geschafft hätte, mir das ging ja auch irgendwie bis bis tief in die Nacht, ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir das angetan hätte und ob ich da nicht irgendwann schreiend rausgerannt wäre oder von der
gesprungen wäre oder irgendwas. Man weiß ja nicht, wie man in extremen Situationen reagiert und irgendwie mehrere Stunden puffaler
das ist halt hart. Hauptsächlich hat man ihn dann da genervt, möchte man sagen. Also sein Eindruck war wohl einfach, dass er da genervt wurde.
Mit der äh mit der Wahlkampflüge von zweitausenddreizehn. Wo es darum, wir erinnern uns, da hat er äh stolz und,
lang und breit vor der äh vor der Öffentlichkeit erklärt, dass es ja bald ein No-Spy-Abkommen geben würde. Und wir erinnern uns auch, dass vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten dann,
der Austausch zwischen den Mitarbeitern des äh Bundeskanzleramtes und der äh der amerikanischen Vertretung öffentlich wurde, in dem.
Die Deutschen immer sagten so, ey es wäre echt voll cool, wenn ihr da mal sowas sagen könntet mit und so und die Amis immer gesagt haben, seid ihr verrückt?
Seid ihr verrückt? Das machen wir nicht. Und am Ende hat sich dann der Mitarbeiter des äh Kanzleramtes dann äh entschuldigt und Besserung gelobt, dass,
dass dass sie davon immer wieder reden würden. Es gab da eine E-Mail, äh die sagt, dass,
Die USA sieht sicherlich sehr irritiert sind, dass die dass Deutschland weiterhin öffentlich von diesem Abkommen äh schwadroniert.
Ja? Und all das hätte natürlich auch wahr selbstverständlich pro Fahrer auch bekannt, als er vor den in der Öffentlichkeit da rumgetanzt ist mit seinem Abkommen. Ja, aber er ist also in diesen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss gegangen und hat dann.
Ausführlich mit Angabe spezifischer Daten äh erzählt, wann er mit wem, über welche äh konkreten Texte,
eine Abkommens gar verhandelt hätte.
Ähm er sei, sagte er selbst nach, noch bei seinem Ausscheiden aus dem Amt äh im äh Dezember zweitausenddreizehn, davon ausgegangen, dass das Nortey-Abkommen quasi vor der Tür steht,
und im Januar zweitausendvierzehn abgeschlossen werden könnte. Und dann ging es aber, wurde er natürlich damit konfrontiert, dass eben nicht von einem,
No-Spy-Abkommen die Rede war? Offenbar, sondern von einer, von einem erneuten.
Memoranum der Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Geheimdiensten, was ja.
In den Augen der Öffentlichkeit dann doch durchaus so ein leichtes leichter Unterschied sein könnte, so. So, ja, wir machen Noese.
Mehr so ein Mores bei Abkommen, ja?
Genau, ein Mores bei Abkommen. Und ungefähr, das sagt genau damit, mit diesem Vorwurf wurde dann auch äh äh mit diesem,
Vorwurf wurde er dann auch konfrontiert und dann sagte er, lassen sie doch mal die Begriffe weg, das ist alles Wurst. Ob's jetzt ein No-Spy-Abkommen ist
oder eine Übereinkunft der Dienste. Und ich meine von jemandem, der Wahlkampf macht, von jemandem, der im Bundeskanzleramt arbeitet, überhaupt,
Also das ist halt die die Last Line of Defense, ja, wenn du wenn dein ganzes News neu sprech irgendwie auffliegt und du dann auf einmal du sagst so, ja, aber Begriffe sind ja Schall und Rauch. Also das ist das muss ganz, ganz
übel gewesen sein.
Aber ne, alles, alles äh in Ordnung, hat das super gemacht. Es stand unmittelbar bevor. Da hat er sich nichts ähm,
hat er sich nix äh vorzuwerfen.
Außerdem hat er dann richtig gestellt und das fand ich, weißt du, also der Pofalla hat zum No-Spy-Abkommen, hat ja nicht gelogen. Hat er ja jetzt erklärt, ne?
Weißt du, was der auch nicht gemacht hat?
Ich ich will auch nochmal kurz erinnern. Ich glaube, wir hätten das irgendwie vorletztes Mal, als ich äh irgendwie meinte, so, sie werden sich schon auf diese Art und Weise weiter rausreden, dass ja irgendjemand irgendwann mal irgendwas gesagt hat und dass sie ja äh die ganze Zeit auch nur diesen Eindruck gehabt hätten
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das irgendwie weiter zu fassen ist. Geschweige denn, dass es jetzt sonderlich wichtig ist, das weiter zu fassen.
Aber er hat in den NSA-Skandal äh.
Nicht für beendet erklärt.
Ist der Hammer, oder?
Hat er ja auch so gar nicht gesagt. Nö, die Worte hat er ja so auch nie benutzt.
Hat er tatsächlich nicht, aber jetzt ist die, jetzt ist die Frage, was hat er denn äh es gibt keine, es geht ja darum, es gibt keine massenhafte äh Ausspähung auf deutschem Boden. Das waren ja so, glaube ich, ungefähr seine Worte,
und damit hat er und das ist jetzt ganz witzig. Das hat er auch erklärt bekommen, nämlich er wollte damit eine,
angebliche Falschbehauptung des Spiegel korrigieren, der nämlich geschrieben hat, dass fünfhundert Millionen oder was Metadaten vom BND.
Monatlich an die NSA weitergegeben würden.
Ja? Das sei also eine Falschbehauptung des Spiegel gewesen, die der Spiegel getätigt hätte und das sei deshalb eine Falschbehauptung gewesen, weil im Spiegel stand.
Meterdaten und es wäre der.
Fünfhundert Millionen Kommunikationen waren das.
Ja genau, da hatten wir sogar meinen Sendungstitel nach, ne.
Genau, das wäre also das das war eine falsch Behauptung, es spiegelt deshalb, weil es zwar inhaltlich stimmte, dass diese fünfhundert Millionen Kommunikationen weitergegeben werden.
Aber dass eben ja Auslandskommunikation sei. Also keine deutschen Mieterdaten.
Deswegen gibt es keine Massenausspähung auf deutschem Boden, weil.
Sie ja von den.
Also es es fällt mir schwer, ihm zu folgen, aber quasi okay, der BND auf deutschem Boden, andere aus, die nicht in Deutschland sind.
Also ist das kein Ausspähen auf deutschem Boden?
Das ist so ähnlich wie diese Weltraumtheorie, ne? Wenn der BND Satelliten abhört, dann tut der das ja nicht auf deutschem Boden und,
Wenn die NSA aber Deutsche überwacht, dann passiert das auch nicht auf deutschem Boden, weil das macht ja die NSA,
Ja? Und deswegen gibt es keine Maßenüberwachung auf deutschem Boden, so ungefähr äh seine äh,
Erklärung dafür. Und dann hat er noch äh am Ende rumgetönt, dass es also dass man jetzt endlich mal aufhören müsste hier mit dieser ganzen NSA-Aufklärerei und so, denn äh langsam würden die Amerikaner ja
sicherlich auch mal fuchsig und dass Deutschland bisher von Anschlägen verschont worden ist, sei also nicht selbstverständlich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er in dem Zusammenhang jetzt auch wirklich äh.
Nochmal also welche Anschläge er da meint, ne, also ob jetzt von den Amerikanern oder von von welchen.
Einen von den bösen Terroristen natürlich, ne? Also das ist sozusagen diese Aussage, äh soll sowas behaupten, wie,
Es könnte ja vielleicht sein, dass das ja der Grund dafür ist, nicht? Weil wir diese ganzen Millionen Kommunikationen hier durchreichen, das würde ja irgendwie auf eine ganz magische Art und Weise dazu führen, dass eben Anschläge äh nicht stattfinden.
Ja
Das ist aber natürlich äh da muss man da muss ja äh muss man leider sagen, dass es eben keine,
keinen Beleg über verhinderte Anschläge gibt, ne? Also sie sie bleiben denen ja schuldig, das wäre ja
das war ja ganz am Anfang, als irgendwie meinten da diese diese Sauerland-Gruppe oder wer das war, ne, die irgendwie eine etwas größere Bestellung Dünger oder sowas mal aufgegeben hatten oder so, ne,
das das war ja der der fürchterliche Anschlag, der da irgendwie verhindert wurde. Also dieses Belege für diese Behauptung ähm,
haben sie nicht, ne? Haben sie ja so, haben ja auch die USA nicht bei ihrem eigenen Überwachungsprogramm.
Ja und ich meine, wird nicht ins zynische umschlagen, aber.
Selbst wenn jetzt mal einer nicht verhindert wird, ja, ich meine, wir müssen sehr wohl natürlich davon ausgehen, dass das denkbar ist. Ja, gibt einfach genug Idioten, äh in jeglichem Lager.
Irgendwie mal durchdrehen. Ja und äh ob man das jetzt Amoklauf oder Terroranschlag nennt, ist dann nochmal eine ganz andere Frage.
Hängt ja mal so ein bisschen davon ab, wer es gerade äh macht im Namen welchen Gottes sozusagen. Ähm das sind auch Dinge, die die wird eine eine Massenüberwachung nicht verhindern können. Das zeigen.
Ja, auch die USA immer wieder.
Ich habe jetzt in den letzten Wochen und Monaten, glaube ich,
von zwei Asylbewerberunterkünften gelesen, die angezündet wurden. Das ist in meinen Augen ein Terroranschlag. Den hätten die mal verhindern können, hätten wir miteinander reden können. Dann wären wir ins Gespräch gekommen,
aber äh das scheint ja in seinen äh in seinen Augen noch nicht mal ein Anschlag zu sein. Übrigens während.
Es geht ja nicht gegen die Freiheit, also nicht unsere. Ne, also von daher.
Da wir, da wir jetzt grade hier so in der Vergangenheit schwelgen und Pofalla noch mal alles erklärt, wie er den NSA-Skandal nicht beendet hat und nicht im Wahlkampf gelogen hat, was einfach beides.
Das ist einfach erbärmlich überhaupt den Versuch zu machen, sich da aus der Nummer rauszureden, aber hat er versucht, ähm die USA waren derweil erstaunt über die zögerliche Reaktion der Deutschen.
Auf,
Enthüllungen der NSA-Spionage, insbesondere die Überwachung des Merkel-Handys. Und zwar geht das aus einem Aktenvermerk des BND hervor, den der Spiegel jetzt irgendwie nächste Woche veröffentlicht wird.
Und da heißt es, die US-Seite hätte harte Reaktionen erwartet, sogar mit einer kurzzeitigen, temporären Einschränkung der Kooperation gerechnet,
oder mit einer Ausweisung von US-Personal gar. Würde Deutschland,
gegen die USA spionieren.
Dann äh würde man mit harten Nachrichtendienstlichen Sanktionen gegen Deutschland vorgehen. Das also die haben sich im Prinzip darüber Schrott gelacht, dass die halten, es muss den mal reinziehen. Die haben da gesessen und gesagt so wie, dann lassen die sich gefallen,
Ich hätte gedacht, jetzt hätten wir wenigstens mal irgendwie.
Irgendwie mal eine Woche keine Zusammenarbeit oder mal irgendwie, dass wir mal anrufen und geht keiner ans Telefon oder so. Das ist ja schon erstaunlich, was die mit sich machen lassen. Das würden wir uns ja nicht gefallen lassen.
Müll.
Geil, oder? Ja, also äh Deutschland lässt sich an der Stelle einfach gerne Ohrfeigen, ne. Also es hat schon so ein bisschen was von ist schon so so ein kleiner SM-Veranstaltungen.
Es ist einfach,
ich weiß nicht, ob das was mit SM zu tun hat. Ich weiß nur, dass ich diesen, dass ich diesen Pofalla wirklich als gesamtes Wesen für den gesamten Politikbetrieb und für jeden Bürger Deutschlands als eine,
eine entwürdigende, als ein entwürdigendes Phänomen empfinde. Das ist eine, das ist wirklich unmöglich der Typ, ja. Also nämlich einerseits.
Da so eine also einerseits die Leute zu belügen andererseits,
eben in dieser außenpolitischen äh im außenpolitischen Verhalten dermaßen zu buckeln, dass selbst die USA sagen, Alter, was sind das denn? So, das hätten wir uns aber nicht gefallen lassen
und dann auch noch irgendwie wieder der große Larry im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss, die den Leuten über den Mund fahren und denen irgendwie einen erzählen, ey, ihr habt doch keine Ahnung so,
Also das ist wirklich da habe ich ganz, ganz wenig Verständnis für.
Und da muss ich tief in in meine äh Schulung als Psychologe zurückgehen, um da noch irgendwie äh einen Faden drin zu finden.
Na gut, aber er scheint sich ja zumindest ganz gut zu bewerben, äh durch sein Verhalten, ne, also wird jetzt hier laut aktueller äh Spiegelhomepage äh als Nachfolger von Herrn Grube im Bahnvorstand äh sozusagen als Chef gehandelt
Also mit den Qualitäten kann man irgendwie auch ein Bahnunternehmen leiten.
Das auf jeden Fall. Also da würde ich jetzt auch sagen, für die Deutsche Bahn heiße ich auf jeden Fall qualifiziert.
Ja, ich meine, stell dir mal vor, also es gäbe einfach keine Verspätungen mehr, die Klimaanlagen würden auf einmal äh aus dem Nichts heraus funktionieren. Hammer.
Würden sie ja gar nicht. Hätte er nie gesagt, ach komm, okay, der Typ. Der Typ. Deswegen, ich weiß nicht, also.
Ich bin so völlig gespalten, ob ich das jetzt gut oder schlecht finde, dass ich nicht in dieser Sitzung war.
Aber so richtig überrascht sind wir jetzt auch nicht.
Ja, aber ne, man muss ja schon mal so ein bisschen schildern, was der Mann so sagt. Also.
Klar, dafür sind.
Ne? Der hat noch ein paar Jahr. Der hat ja noch der Mann ist ja, weiß ich, der ist wahrscheinlich wenn der jetzt also wenn der Fünfzig ist, dann ist er es noch nicht lange,
Das heißt, der hat noch, wenn der, wenn du dir mal anguckst, was so ein Medorn, der bis ins hohe Alter noch äh so da musst du mal überlegen, der Mann hat noch drei, drei Jahrzehnte Schadenspotenzial, auf jeden Fall,
Ja, da muss man jetzt schon mal irgendwie gucken, dass man, dass man dafür sorgt, dass der wenigstens aktenkundig ist.
Ja, das war das Problem bei den Medorn. Der lassen wir es, aber der der hat der Medon hat nicht einen einzigen Erfolg.
In seiner gesamten Karriere, im wirtschaftlichen Bereich, nicht einen einzigen. Den einzigen Wert der einzigen äh
Das einzige Mal, dass dein Unternehmen mit wirtschaftlichem Erfolg verlassen hat, haben die alles, was der gemacht in den nächsten fünf Jahren sofort wieder rückgängig gemacht, um das Unternehmen zu retten
Das war das einzige Unternehmen, was besser äh da stand, nachdem er gegangen war und das das verstand halt kurz vorm Ruin. Egal. Wiki Leaks.
Genau.
WikiLeaks hat ähm ein bisschen veröffentlicht über die ähm.
Die NSA-Spionage an der deutschen Regierung. Da haben sie so drei veröffentlicht, also drei Berichte über abgehörte Gespräche.
Dann ähm NSA Selektoren Telefonanschlüsse.
Sechsundzwanzig Stück an der Zahl von also eine Liste, von der sie sagen, dass sie ähm.
Sechsundzwanzig oder sechsundfünfzig?
Sechsundfünfzig, glaube ich.
Letzten fünfzehn, glaube ich, auch.
Von der sie sagen, dass sie zweitausendzwei standardisiert wurde, aber so weit bis in das Jahr neunzehnhundertachtundneunzig zurückgeht.
Also seitdem wird sie schon gepflegt, also schon in den neunziger Jahren waren äh Regierungsmitglieder und äh hochrangige Politiker in Deutschland ähm,
Zielperson der NSA. Ähm.
Und da sagen sie also, Oskar Lafontaine, der ja mal kurz deutscher Finanzminister war, in dem ersten,
dann Kabinett Schröder, der dann ihr aber gesagt hat, okay
was ihr hier vorhabt, mache ich nicht mit. Dennis Lafontaine gegangen. Dann gab's diese ganze WASG, die Linke und so weiter Gründung, während äh Gerhard Schröder als damals als sozialdemokratischer
Bundeskanzler dann die Agenda zwanzig zehn gemacht hat. Das war ja das, was Oscar Lafontaine nicht ähm mittragen wollte. Also so weit geht das zurück.
Unter anderem. Ja, ich glaube, da äh war auch äh dagegen hier die Hedgefones äh zuzulassen im deutschen Finanzsystem.
Ja, der war gegen alles, was der, was der Schröder gemacht hat. Deswegen äh sah er dann halt auch ein Jahr später schon als äh Finanzminister zurückgetreten zur äh großen Enttäuschung vieler.
Aber quasi ist schon Oskalafon, den ich wollte eigentlich nur zum Ausdruck bringen, wie lange das her ist, war halt schon auf dieser Liste. So alt ist diese Liste. Ähm,
Die Regierung von Helmut Kohl, Gerhard Schröder und Angela Merkel befinden sich da drauf
Die halbe Mannschaft von Ex-Kanzler Schröder, darunter Bodo Hombach, der Kanzleramtsminister war, äh für eine kurze Zeit und irgendwie in Naost
irgendwie rum operiert hat, Sicherheit sein sicherheitspolitischer Berater Michael Steiner,
Schröders Mann für den Weltwirtschaftsgipfel Klaus Kretschmann, Ronald Pofalla, steht auch auf der Liste,
Mit seiner bis heute aktiven Handynummer haha, ja, also.
Woher weißt du das?
Ich lese immer äh Medien. Ähm also die die äh Süddeutsche und so hatten, die ähm,
Süddeutsch und so hatten die Wiki Leaks Materialien in der unzensierten Form schon vorher zur Recherche vorliegen,
in der Veröffentlichung sind die letzten drei ähm Digitals von den von den Telefonnummern geixt, wie bei, ne, damit.
Die letzten vier sogar. Hm. Mhm.
Jetzt in vier sogar. Ja, du liest auch. Ne, äh die letzten.
Medien, richtig, richtig, richtig geil.
Heftig, ne? Liste auch neue Medien?
Nur.
Und äh soziale.
Auch da auch.
Ähm.
Vor allem viel schlechter.
Investigative Medien auch.
Bisweilen.
Okay, also die die Telefonnummern sind geixt, aber diese ähm.
Dieses Rechercheteam der äh SZ die haben dann wahrscheinlich auch mal die Nummern gewählt oder einfach mal geguckt, welche Nummern sie halt im in ihren äh,
in der Cloud haben bei Apple von und äh festgestellt, ja die Nummer gibt es noch so.
Dann äh den Chef der Abteilung zwei des Kanzleramts für Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik,
den Leiter der Abteilung für Wirtschaftspolitik und eben auch die Abteilung sechs. Ja, das heißt also, dieser profaller und der Herr, wie heißt der noch, Kreis, ne, hieß er, glaube ich, heiß.
Waren also auch können also auch davon ausgehen, dass sie abgehört wurden, ja?
Das finde ich ganz witzig.
Und vor allem ist interessant, dass diese Dokumente vermutlich nicht aus dem Snowdenfundus stammen, ne?
Sondern jetzt da so offenbar hat Wiki Leaks jetzt auch nochmal jemanden an der Hand und macht da jetzt rührt da jetzt ordentlich äh an der.
In der Suppe. Die drei Intersets, das war einmal private,
private ein privates Gespräch zwischen Angela Merkel und ihrem persönlichen Assistenten, dann ein Gespräch zwischen ihr und dem,
Generaldirektor für EU-Angelegenheiten Nikolas Meyer-Landrut und dann noch ein.
Ein der Details der deutschen Position in der Verhandlung zu einem EU-Bayout,
für Griechenland hat. Also das, was jetzt äh was wir auch im Intro-Kurz referenziert haben, ne?
Wo sich Angela Merkel äh offenbar nicht sicher war, welche Position sie einnehmen sollte. Gegenüber Griechenland.
Und das zeigt halt auch, wie kurz also, okay, die Griechenland-Debatte wird's auch schon seit längerer Zeit geführt, aber sie sind also relativ neu und äh es gibt eben äh sehr gute Anzeichen darauf, dass sie eben nicht aus dem,
nicht von Edwards Noten stammen, was zu begrüßen ist, weil dann gibt's jemand anderen.
Ja, das stimmt. Es ist nicht sogar nicht nur naheliegend, sondern in gewisser Hinsicht, ich meine, man weiß doch auch von wann die sind, oder? Also.
Genau. Ja, ja, also gerade.
Die Frage ist, sind Sie in den letzten zwei Jahren äh angefertigt worden, ne?
Ja, das mussten wir jetzt einfach.
Im Planer mit Griechenland, das läuft ja schon länger, das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau.
Persönliche Gespräch. Weiß nicht, ob da überhaupt irgendeine Datierung vorgenommen war. Aber grundsätzlich, ich meine, du hast ja vorhin gesagt, aus seit Oscar Fontänen
äh sei das ja schon so, aber wenn schon die Regierung von Helmut Kohl äh auf dieser Liste sein soll, dann geht das ja noch deutlich weiter zurück.
Also, weil äh das äh Lafontaine war ja erst ab äh achtundneunzig in der Regierung und ähm,
Bis dahin hatten wir ja die Kur-Regierung und das geht ja dann wiederum zurück bis in die Dinosaurierzeit.
Also diese Griechenland-Geschichte, das ist das Neueste dieser Intersets ist, zweitausendelf.
Gut, das sagt er noch nicht so viel aus.
Ja genau, aber okay. Ah. Schön kann man auch nochmal gucken, äh aber Wikileaks hat ja noch was viel schöneres gerade bei sich gehostet.
Warte mal kurz, äh ich war ähm ein bisschen enttäuscht, weil ich so las so, ah, jetzt hier endlich selektoren und so und ich dachte jetzt, geil, endlich mal, richtige SQL-Drinks und so. Ah, jetzt waren das alles nur Telefonnummern.
Oder hast du da was anderes gesehen? Ich habe nur Telefonnummern gesehen.
Denke, dass äh.
Dass das eben auch so ist, ne? Also die der du die werden ja die Analysten werden da ja schon jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie reines SGL schreiben müssen, sondern die haben halt eine Suchmaske und,
Dinge, die ihnen angeboten werden und so. Ich glaube, wahrscheinlich, dass,
Also die äh so, ich meine, es wäre natürlich schön, mal so einen SQL Dumm oder sowas zu bekommen, aber ich glaube, dass das letztendlich das ist das, was ein Selektor ist, ne.
Ja gut, es könnte genauso gut auch eine E-Mail-Adresse sein.
Genau, das könnte auch äh was weiß ich, Bobby Drop Table sein.
Ja genau, aber es war halt nur Telefonnummern, deswegen war ich jetzt so ein bisschen enttäuscht,
Selektoren äh hält's auch schon vor zwanzig, dreißig Jahren gegeben, wenn auch keine äh Mobilfunknummern. Äh von daher warte ich dann sozusagen auch mal auf was was so ein bisschen nach nach äh moderner Zeit aussieht, ne.
Ja, das stimmt, da war sogar noch eine Faxnummer von Merkel mit dabei.
Farks, puh geht ab. So, was war noch so schön bei bei WikiLeaks?
Richtig schön, richtig schön, hat gar nichts mit zu tun, aber ist hat Wiki Leak sehr schön aufgearbeitet. Ähm.
Also, es gibt ja Staatstrojaner,
und diese Staatstrojaner äh werden ja äh jetzt spreche ich also nicht von den von den militärischen Hacking äh,
Cruise, von denen, über die wir in in der, ich glaube, in der vorletzten Sendung längere Zeit mal gesprochen haben, sondern jetzt spreche ich von eher von Law and forcement, ja?
Also Polizei und vielleicht inländische Geheimdienste. Also eher nicht Spionage gegen,
andere Regierungen, sondern Spionage gegen oder Hacking-Angriffe gegen die eigene Bevölkerung.
Sogenannten Staatstrojaner. Wir erinnern uns, der CCC hat vor einigen Jahren den ersten äh deutschen Staatstrojaner.
In seine Finger bekommen, analysiert und äh die Sicherheitslücken darin veröffentlicht. Ähm,
auch die Software selber, so dass sie dann eben in äh von Virenscannern erkannt wurde. Das heißt, da ist ein eine,
ist es gelungen,
dem Unternehmen, was diesen Staatstrojaner hergestellt hat, die Firma Digitalsk äh massiv zu schaden und auch dem Unternehmen äh dieser Unternehmung Staatstrojaner äh in Deutschland ein jähes Ende zu setzen.
Ähm dann wurde die Bühne frei für Unternehmen, die.
Oder die Bühne war, die auch schon vorher auf diesem Markt agiert haben, aber die das sagen wir mal ein bisschen besser, die sich ein bisschen geschickter anstellen als ähm als Digitastro, dieser digital Trojaner war wirklich von minderer Qualität. Ähm,
und.
Es gibt also zwei Unternehmen, die ähm sage ich mal, denen im Ruf stehen äh bessere Staatstrojaner bereitzustellen und das ist äh einmal die Firma Gamma,
und einmal die Firma Hacking Team. Andere Firmen, die ich jetzt nicht nenne, äh mögen es mir verzeihen. Äh die kommen, die bekommen dann bei uns Werbung, wenn auch sie gehackt wurden. Denn Gamma wurde vor ein paar Monaten
gehackt und relativ
viele ihrer Daten, die dir Angreifer da so in seine Hände bekommen hat, äh als Torint veröffentlicht. Darunter so eine schöne SQR, die die SQL-Datenbank ihres Kunden Support Forums. Ähm,
aus der sich dann relativ schön ableiten ließ in welchem Land sie überall Kunden haben. Allerdings hatten die bei Gamma durchaus einen relativ.
Also die hatten ein relativ hohes Schutz- und Datenschutzniveau, zum Beispiel die ganzen Kundenaccounts in diesen.
In diesem Kunden-Support-Forum waren alle auf so generische E-Mail-Adressen auf dem eigenen Server. Ähm die haben sehr, sodass du nicht sehen konntest, wer das
ist, der da den Support-Request stellt, sondern du musst es dir dann quasi dessen, deren Schilderungen,
durchlesen, weil's dann häufig mal so geschildert haben, ja, äh hier in äh so und so hier in bei Swiss Com sieht's so und so aus oder hier in Aserbaidschan. Ich habe die
sowohl den Firmennamen als auch das Land jetzt erfunden, äh dass sie sich halt verplappert haben in diesem Support-Forum oder gesagt haben, ja, schick mal an meine private E-Mail-Adresse oder sonstwas, ja?
Ähm außerdem hatten sie halt äh und so, aber es waren immer so äh PGP verschlüsselte Dateien, also bei bei Gamma war der Hack
relativ wenig erfolgreich, hatte aber natürlich trotzdem den großen PR Schaden für Gamma, dass sie äh gehackt wurden.
Und die entsprechende Häme. So, nun.
Gab es, gibt es einen zweiten, nennenswerten Konkurrenten von Gamma, das ist die
italienische Firma Hacking Team. Ach so, vielleicht noch sogar mal kurz zu sagen, Gamma eben in in vielen Ländern irgendwie mit allen möglichen kleinen Firmen aktiv, um sich irgendwie dem Problem der Exportrestriktion nicht aussetzen zu müssen.
Und äh,
wurde hier in Deutschland, glaube ich, über die Firma Edermann oder sowas oder Edermann äh vertrieben. Aber um um Gamma geht's ja gar nicht. Das war ja nur der erste Streich, denn die Firma Hacking Team, der direkte Konkurrent von Gamma, mit dem,
remote Control System, so nennen sie ihren Trojaner Gamma, nennt ihren Finn Fischer oder Finn Spy, ähm Hacking Team nennen
ihren intern remote Control System und äh der Produktname ist, glaube ich, Galileo oder so, ja? Ähm,
Eine Firma aus Milano, Italien, die eben auch ein Staatstrojaner verkauft und.
Der dieser Firma wurde jetzt empfindlich äh empfindlicher Schaden zugefügt durch einen Hack des Gleichen,
Hackers, der auch ähm,
die äh Finn Fischer Geschichte gemacht hat, die Gamma-Geschichte. Nur dieses Mal hat er sich nicht so schnell zufrieden gegeben, sondern hat da,
länger seine äh Netze ausgespannt und hat das hat die mal so von vorne bis hinten vollständig auseinander genommen. Und.
Das hat dazu geführt, dass jetzt alle Softwareprodukte, die die es gibt, dazu gehören ja jetzt nicht nur gehört nicht nur ein Trojaner, sondern einfach mal sechs Trojaner, nämlich für jede Betriebssystemvariante, also Linux, Windows Mac,
Android äh Windows Phone iOS, ja, sechs unterschiedliche Trojaner-Geschmäcker. Dann auch eine Infection Engin, also
wenn du deinen Staatstrojaner hast, musst du dir ja überlegen, wie du den auf den Computer des Opfers bekommst. Du kannst ja nicht immer nur darauf warten, dass er mal äh, dass das Opfer mal irgendwie am Flughafen
kurz in die wir müssen mal eben ihren Computer kontrollieren, wir sind gleich wieder da, Kontrolle kommt und man irgendwie
seine Hände an das Gerät bekommt und den Staatstrojaner draufmacht, sondern man möchte ja vielleicht auch so 'n mal so 'n Flash Explor zum Einsatz bringen, na? Also Mittelangriffe machen,
den äh mit einem Drive bei Exploit den Trojaner auf dem Zielsystem ähm unterbringen,
dafür haben sie also auch eine eine Engin gehabt, eine Infection Engin, wo man dann so quasi so sich das Explode aussucht und sagt, hier jetzt äh ne, draufhauen. Ähm.
Unterschiedliche, also ihre Commanden Control Infrastruktur ist eine Riesenmenge an, die ich auch noch nicht vollständig gelesen habe.
Und auch noch nicht vollständig gesichtet habe. All das findet sich jetzt auf GITHUP. Dann befindet sich ein Großteil der E-Mails,
Geschäftsführers und der Mitarbeiter in einem und jetzt auch sehr schön ähm
händisch durchsuchbar, bei Wiki Leaks, so mit Suchmaske, wo man dann halt so Namen eingeben kann,
Suchbegriffe, gibt man mal BKA ein und dann sieht man so, dass halt irgendwie so ein BKA-Mitarbeiter äh sich gerne mal eine Produkt
Präsentation von denen anschauen möchte und deshalb eine Delegation des Bundeskriminalamtes
nach Italien fliegt, um sich äh zum Verkaufsgespräch mit dem Hacking Team äh zu treffen oder eine Mail.
Des FBI oder,
von einem Fallser einfach mal die gesamten Kontrakte, die sie mit den unterschiedlichen Firmen hatten, zum Beispiel irgendwie äh Geschäftsabschlüsse mit dem FBI über, ich glaube, insgesamt äh siebenhunderttausend Dollar
ähm oder auch Geschäfts äh Verträge mit der Deutschen Bank, die bei denen allerdings offenbar keinen äh,
Trojaner, sondern ein Penetration-Test äh gekauft hat. Also die haben nicht nur dieses äh Staatstrojaner-Produkt verkauft.
Also vierhundertachtzig Gigabyte insgesamt ist dieser Torent groß.
Ein ein Fest, denn da drin befinden sich dann auch so Geschichten wie einmal alle Passwörter von dem Geschäftsführer.
Ja, so für äh.
Klartext oder was?
Für ja in Klartext, für LinkedIn und hast du alles nicht gesehen. LinkedIn, Amazon, eBay
Paypal, alles. Das war auch nicht so schwer, denn das Passwort von dem Geschäftsführer einer Firma, die Staatstrojaner entwickelt, um
Menschen für andere, für für Staaten und Regierungen zu hacken, dessen Lieblingspasswort war Passwort.
Ja, aber sicher. PASS W null RD Hacker, ne.
Oh, Junge, er hat aber noch mal einen Haken geschlagen. Da kommt ja keiner.
Hat er einen Haken geschlagen. Da damit wird auch klar, warum es der Angreifer in diesem Fall jetzt ein bisschen einfacher hatte
bei denen mal richtig alles aufzumachen, ne? Und wenn der halt auf dem, wenn der Chef jetzt auf dem Fightserver auch dieses Passwort hatte, dann ist halt auch klar, wieder einfach mal an allen Quelltext gekommen ist. Übrigens auch an ein Flash Zero Day.
Das äh zusammen mit einer Windows-Lücke,
Chrome Sandbox bei Pass ermöglicht. Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu erklären. Flash ist ja ein Flash ist ja ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz besonders gefährlich und unsicher und,
was man versucht mit so Software, der man nicht trauen kann, ist sie in irgendwie einzusperren, ja? Also eine Technik ist zum Beispiel sie in einer,
virtuellen Maschine auszuführen. Das macht man zum Beispiel ganz gerne mit dem Betriebssystem Windows, was ja inhend
schadhaft ist. Also macht meine virtuelle Maschine, damit man seinen eigenen Computer nicht äh und seine eigenen Daten nicht in in Gefahr bringt. So ähnlich,
muss man sich eine Sandbox vorstellen, bei der quasi ein Prozess, ein Programm.
In einer virtuellen Umgebung läuft, in der.
Es keinen Zugriff auf den Rest des Systems hat. Und das macht Chrome mit Flash,
Die sagen also, okay, ist in Ordnung, wir gehen davon aus, dass Flash äh andauernd aufgemacht wird, dass es da Unmengen an für gibt, aber wenn der Angreifer aus unserem Flash,
aus unserem mitgelieferten Flash rausklettert, dann findet er eine Umgebung, in der er nichts am am eigentlichen Wirtsystem anrichten kann. Das nennt sich Sandbox,
Habe ich das jetzt gut erklärt, Tim, oder.
Ja, das war, nö, das war jut. Wobei mir wieder klar geworden ist, wie.
Sandkasten nun wirklich, ich meine, wer schon mal versucht hat, aus einem Sandkasten zu entkommen.
Vor allem.
In gewisser Hinsicht sagt das einiges über die etablierten Security-Technologien aus. Vielleicht sollte man lieber von so einem Verließ sprechen oder so.
Ich habe mich ja über was viel Besseres, Tim. Geh mal auf Google Image äh Search und gib mal Sandbox ein, ja? Und dann guck dir mal diese Sandkisten an, wo überall so haufenweise Sand daneben geworfen wurde. So muss man sich eine Sandbox vorstellen.
Hier so. Äh wir machen da mal einen, das machen wir mal als als Bild mit.
Ja, da ist echt und das ist äh sind halt wirklich sehr niedrige Hürden, die da äh überwunden werden müssen.
Also ich muss schon das ist schon mitunter also die Chrom Sandbox das ist schon.
Nein, das ist mir schon klar, aber äh du wirst ja jetzt gleich ausholen und sagen, dass die Zero Day,
Genau, das ist Ihnen ja mit diesen Zero Days auch gelungen ist. Äh auch diese Sandbox zu überwinden, also es ist jetzt nicht unmöglich. Ich glaube, Apple macht auch was Ähnliches. Ja, also.
Apple macht das mit jedem einzelnen Programm, weil man eben zum Beispiel nicht möchte, dass äh also jedes einzelne Programm läuft in einer Sandbox, weil du eben nicht möchtest, dass eine Sicherheitslücke in diesem Programm dazu führt, dass dieses Programm plötzlich irgendwie in dem System rumwütet
habe ich übrigens jetzt auch bei neueren äh.
MacOS Applikation festgestellt, dass die in in, dass es da so eine rudimentäre Sandbox für gibt, die dann also.
Nee, was du jetzt meinst, ist sozusagen generell jeglich, also es gilt übrigens für Software, die man im App Store kauft und nur die.
Und äh aber was jetzt sozusagen nochmal Flash betrifft,
das läuft dann im Safari auch noch mal in einem separaten Prozess und wird sozusagen nochmal extra gekapselt, um auch an der Stelle nochmal das Schlimmste zu verhindern, inwiefern das jetzt nochmal als eigenes Handbox äh sich qualifiziert, weiß ich nicht, kann ich.
Nee, das ist, also Sandbox ist schon ein bisschen mehr, also das heißt, du gibst dem Ding halt eine Umgebung, in der es sich dann auch äh äh,
quasi von mir aus auch austoben kann, ja? Ähm eigener Prozess hätte halt immer noch deine deine Hostumgebung. Aber gehen wir da mal nicht ins Detail. Also die
Königsklasse dis remote Explodes. Ist es ähm eine Webseite.
War ich immer und nee, sagen wir mal so, ähm.
Es gäbe natürlich noch einen noch besseren Remotexploit, wo der Nutzer gar nichts machen muss. Das wäre dann so die Königsklasse, einfach System ist da und ich mache es kaputt. Aber so die Königsklasse des Web Explods ist also der sogenannte, bei dem ich,
nur dem Nutzer eine der Nutzer nur eine Webseite besuchen muss, Klammer auf, ich kann ja auch seine Webseiten in seinen Traffic eingreifen und seine Webseiten verändern.
Ähm und dann ein eine Schwachstelle, erst den,
Flash Player zum zum crashen bringt und zum Ausführen von Code, den der Angreifer bestimmt, dann dieser Code nochmal aus der Sandbox des Flash Players rausklettert,
dann, dass tatsächliche Betriebssystem.
Auf diesem Betriebssystem nochmal Administrator äh Privilegien bekommt und dann eine,
persistente Infektion des Systems vornimmt. Das wäre also so und das sind mehrere Schritte, die dafür notwendig sind. Und diese Einzelschritte wer kannst du eben auf einem Schwarzmarkt kaufen?
Und das hat Hacking Team gemacht.
Die haben sich also äh unter anderem in ihrer äh Liste einen Flash äh Zero Day gehabt, den sie den Kunden eben zur Verfügung gestellt haben. So und was heißt Zero-Day? Zero-Day heißt eine Sicherheitslücke, deren,
Existenz öffentlich unbekannt ist. Das heißt, sie ist in der aktuellsten Version.
Software vertreten, muss nicht notwendigerweise sein, ne, aber in einer gängigen Version sollte sie schon sein, sonst ist der Zero Day nicht so viel wert. Und,
sie ist ähm ausnutzbar.
Und es gibt keine öffentliche Dokumentation davon, das heißt, selbst der Hersteller weiß nichts davon und wird in absehbarer Zeit vermutlich nichts dagegen tun, ja? Und sowas hatte ähm.
Hacking Team eben auch in ihrem Besitz und das ist jetzt auch öffentlich geworden, ja? Und das ist natürlich ganz interessant, weil.
Sich also jetzt in der Wildnis ein Flash Zero Day befindet. Was,
eigentlich nicht so oft passiert. Also die die meisten Flash Sicherheitslücken werden irgendwie von Forschern gefunden und gefixt bevor sie ausgenutzt werden. Ein Zero-Day per Definition äh,
wird eben nicht dem fix zugeführt, sondern eben eher der Ausnutzung. Und.
Ein dieser war dann eben in der Öffentlichkeit und dann war natürlich das Gejammer groß, weil man sagt, jetzt kann ja jeder diesen Flash Zero Day zum Einsatz bringen, jetzt muss äh Adobe.
Außerhalb der des normalen Zyklus ein Notfall-Update für.
Bereitstellen, um diese.
Um diesen um zu verhindern, dass das kriminelle äh diese Sicherheitslücke ausnutzen.
Und ähm um das mal kurz zu relativieren, das Update, was dann eben notfallmäßig released wurde, hat fünfunddreißig Lücken geschlossen in Flash, ja. Also dieser eine war jetzt sicherlich nicht äh
irgendwas, was den Kohl fett macht und ähm das ist leider natürlich auch der Preis, den man zahlen muss, wenn denn ausgenutzt wurde, diese Lücke ja ohnehin schon durch die Veröffentlichung wurde dann jetzt
wenigstens darauf hingewirkt, dass sie in Zukunft nicht mehr ausgenutzt werden kann. Und deswegen war es gut und richtig, äh diese zu veröffentlichen.
Die meisten, sorry.
Wenn wenn die Leute in der Lage sind, ihre Software auch zu aktualisieren, also der Prozess des also allein des der Prozesse Softwareupdates, die man durchgehen muss, um irgendwie seinen Flash zu aktualisieren, ist immer noch so dermaßen furchtbar schlecht.
Ja, man darf halt auch kein Flash auf dem Computer installieren, das weiß man ja. Aber ähm zum, also zum.
Zwei Sachen dazu. Äh Dobby hat, glaube ich, vor ungefähr,
anderthalb Jahren oder so, haben die doch ihren Update so ein Auto-Update und so was gemacht, der jetzt auf jedem System läuft und den du ganz schwer abgeschaltet bekommst. Das heißt, die die haben schon sehr stark daran gearbeitet, die Updates
stärker pushen zu können, aber trotzdem ist der Prozess immer noch natürlich ein Schmerz im Arsch und äh deswegen machen's halt viele Nutzer nicht.
Aber okay, das das Problem hast du immer. Wer seine Rechner nicht updatet, der braucht im soll eben nachher auch nicht quengeln. Ähm und wer Flash installiert sowieso nicht. Aber äh,
das ist also jetzt geschehen.
Ja, ich finde, man könnte auch mal äh also auf die User einzuschlagen, ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu einfach an der Stelle, weil die können das nicht unbedingt einschätzen.
Man mag ja mal davon gehört zu haben, ja? Aber es ist ja auch so, dass man äh nach wie vor von,
populären Webseiten äh geradezu getrieben wird. Dazu dieses Flash zu installieren, weil es ja von vielen Webseiten auch als absolut alternativlos hingestellt wird. Ja, allen voran in Deutschland äh.
Spiegel DE, ja.
Was? Da brauchst du auch keinen Flash. Ach so, für die Videos, ne?
Ja, natürlich, die Videos, die du dir die ganze Zeit da in die Nase geknallt bekommst. Top Meldungen, hier Video, geil, ja, wo dann irgendwie nix passiert, äh aber irgendwie auf jeden Fall schon mal dreißig Sekunden Werbung eingespult wird,
Und da sie irgendwie offensichtlich ihren ganzen Werbeprozess,
Ich weiß nicht, äh entweder noch nicht haben umstellen wollen oder nicht können, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, woran's liegt, weil auf Geräten ohne äh Flash-Möglichkeiten scheint es ja auch zu funktionieren. Trotz alledem auf der Stop-Computern wird er immer noch Flash and Forst. So, also
auch das ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin sich mal den Schuh anziehen und dann könnte ich jetzt auch noch einige andere Webseiten nennen. Das ist einfach auch unverantwortlich ist den Leuten äh so was auf die Nase zu drücken, weil die installieren's dann auch.
Es ist verbreitet, es bleibt verbreitet, weil es einfach von diesen Webseiten alternativlos gemacht wird. Es ist so, ja, du musst Flash installieren, sonst kannst du hier kein Video angucken, als ob's irgendwie nicht schon seit äh vielen Jahren,
ausreichend Alternativen dazu gäbe.
Ja, aber bleiben wir mal noch kurz bei der beim Hacking Team. Ähm also ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem, aber äh zum Glück äh werden wir das hoffentlich ja auch los, ne. Ähm.
Das hoffe ich schon lange.
Das war eben auch nur ein Explode, ne. Sie haben auch alle möglichen anderen. Da gibt's auch eine zum Beispiel auch sehr schön,
Fand ich auch sehr spannend. Also die, wie gesagt, das sind vierhundertachtzig Gigabyte. Das ist eine ganze Menge Spaß, den man da noch drin finden kann, ne. Unter anderem so eine Liste, welche Android-Telefone sie exporten und infizieren können, mit welcher Android-Version und welche nicht?
Auch schon mal ganz interessant, ja? Also um mal zu sehen so äh schlummert in meinem System was oder nicht? Und ne, weil wie gut bin ich aufgestellt oder so, ne?
Android in der Regel sowieso relativ schlecht. Ähm.
Wiki Leaks, wie gesagt, hat's zum Beispiel eine sehr schöne äh Liste mit den mit den E-Mails so eine Suchmaske, wo man halt Begriffe eingeben kann und zu allen möglichen Sachen was findet. Aber was ich jetzt so, wir wir,
fluche hier die ganze Zeit so über Hacking Team, mal die Kundenliste, ja? Also unter anderem den Sudan Kasachstan,
Aserbaidschan, USA FBI, ja, also nur so,
lumpenreine Demokratien auf der Kundenliste, wo sie da so hin liefern, ja? Äh das ist also auch der Grund, warum mich das mit so einer offenen Häme.
Äh äh erfüllt
zu sehen, dass diese Firma also jetzt wirklich einfach vor den Scherben steht. Also es wäre für mich wirklich sehr verwunderlich, wenn die sich von dem Scheiß noch
einmal im Leben wieder erholen könnten. Also es liegt einfach alles, ja, die haben nichts mehr so. Ihr gesamter Quelltext liegt auf dem Internet, ihre gesamte E-Mail-Korrespondenz liegt im Internet, wo sie dann irgendwie sich auch über, ne, über bestimmte prominente
Aktivisten gegen Staatstrojaner natürlich auslassen, ne, also irgendwie den äh Chris Toyan, da hat irgendwie einer fabuliert in einer E-Mail, äh also ist der Chief Technologies, bei der American Liberty,
Union, äh wo jemand halt sagt, ja, da könnte ich mir gut vorstellen, äh den umzubringen oder sowas, ne?
Dann gibt's irgendwie, ja wobei da muss man da jetzt auch nicht, ne? Äh ich glaube, also ich meine, da möchte ich jetzt auch nicht äh drüber äh,
drüber stolpern, über wen ich jetzt vielleicht auch schon gesagt habe, dass das da vielleicht äh,
Humankapital an dieser Person verschwendet wird oder so, ne? Aber Christo Golian wird also relativ oft ähm,
äh relativ oft erwähnt, ja, es ist ein jemand, mit an dem sie echt einen Narren gefressen haben,
Darauf kann er sicherlich auch sehr stolz sein, ehrlich gesagt. Ähm dann irgendwie sowas wie.
Stell dir mal vor, stell dir mal vor, alle deine Sachen,
du bist du bist auf einmal auf Wiki Leaks Ex-Post als der als einer, der für die böseste äh Firma der Welt arbeitet.
Ironisch, weil das jetzt natürlich so auf Wikileaks ist und diese E-Mail dann halt auch auf Wiki Leaks äh veröffentlicht ist. Ähm.
Das alles war der Chef irgendwie das Passwort Password hat.
Ja, das ist wirklich, also das ist halt, ich meine, da kenne ich auch keine keine Gnade, ne.
Die ist super.
Technology
Deaktivis. Enorm
über ähm meckern sie sehr viel, ja, auch über die IFF, aber natürlich, ich meine, man muss das auch so sehen. Ähm.
Dass sie in den Sudan liefern, wo irgendwie bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände herrschen, äh sehen, dafür haben sie sicherlich auch eine gute Erklärung.
Aber die äh Mitarbeiter und Geschäftsführer dieser Firmen, die diese Überwachungstechnologien herstellen und vertreiben, haben.
Von sich so ein bisschen das Bild, dass ihr.
Die Speerspitze im Kampf gegen den Terrorismus und äh die äh den Kindesmissbrauch sind, ne? Weil ihr Produkt wird ja ausschließlich gegen potentielle Terroristen.
Und äh gegen äh Pädophile eingesetzt, die ja alle äh ne uns und der Gesellschaft,
schaden und die unsere größte Sorge sind, wie wir in jeder Statistik erkennen äh und da denken da holen die halt ihre ähm moralische,
Rechtfertigung ihres Handelns her. Und entsprechend haben die genau wie äh unser äh Innenminister und der Wolfgang Schäuble. Ähm natürlich ein sehr, sehr äh
anderes Bild von Menschen, die demokratische,
Prinzipien hoch halten. Und das zeigt sich eben auch in diesen E-Mails. So.
Stilles Schweigen. Ich soll ja immer auch die andere Seite darstellen. Will ich ja auch hier mal so machen, ne. Ähm.
Aber ich würde sagen, so diese Firma ist jetzt äh.
Ist jetzt wirklich erledigt. So. Sie haben dann noch irgendwie eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, in der sie das natürlich verurteilen und ne, die ganzen Terroristen und und Vergewaltiger, die jetzt halt irgendwie frei rumlaufen werden, weil weil sie nicht mehr hinter Gitter gebracht werden können. Und ähm
überhaupt das, was jetzt gefixt wird, was sie sich sicherlich teuer irgendwo gekauft haben. Ich glaube, bei so einem Russen ähm.
Ja
Ich find's schön, ich find's ganz gut und ich find's auch sehr, sehr ironisch, dass ausgerechnet so ein Unternehmen eben so äh so schlechte Sicherheitsvorkehrungen dann eben hatte. Noch nicht mal irgendwie ihre E-Mails verschlüsselt oder so. Also.
Ja, ist geil, oder? Ja, also äh ich habe äh Entschuldigung mit einem Auge mir noch mal den Twitter Stream von dem Christopher angeschaut.
Ja?
Der äh ganz fleißig äh aus diesem äh Material da äh schöpft und äh interessante Thesen formuliert et cetera. Ähm,
nicht nur jetzt über seine äh den Vorschlag ihnen äh schießen zu lassen oder was auch immer, sondern überhaupt auch generell zu,
et cetera, liebste Aufforderung, dass auch vielleicht langsam mal irgendwie auf ähm äh HTML fünf Video und äh TLS umschalten sollten et cetera.
Um unser aller Sicherheit da zu erhöhen, weil auch das ist natürlich eine Quelle von installiert mal Flash.
Ja, ja, ja, äh.
Einfach mal sehen und äh the Power of Video äh müssen wir, glaube ich, nicht weiter betonen an der Stelle.
Also einmal eine Sache von äh installieren war Flash und andererseits halt eine Sache von ähm,
ja, also das ist auch etwas, was man vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal betonen kann, wenn wir diese, wenn wenn
also diese einfachen, männende Mittel mal eben was anderes einspeisen und dann noch einen Exploit runterbringen. Das ist halt nur bei unverschlüsselten
oder unsauber verschlüsselten Verbindungen möglich, wenn man.
Eine vernünftige, verschlüsselte Verbindung hat und irgendwie so, hm, was weiß ich, zum Beispiel, HTTPS Everyware hat, was eben auch an das SSL Observatory von,
Der IFF angeschlossen ist, dann hat man relativ gute Wahrscheinlichkeit, einen mähenden Mittelangriff bei
verschlüsselten Verbindungen zu erkennen. Zumindest, dass die Software einen warnt, ob man selber den dann auch erkennt, ist noch was anderes. Ähm,
ebenso einem so einem einfachen Infektionsweg da äh nicht ausgesetzt zu sein. Solange also jedes unverschlüsselte Browsen kann eben nicht nur mitgehört werden, sondern eben auch verändert werden.
Genau und da ist zum Beispiel auch sehr äh kann man mal auch lobend äh erwähnen. Ich weiß nicht, das war jetzt glaube ich auch erst vor Kurzem, dass Google generell alle Suchanfragen auf HTPS umleitet, also selbst wenn ich mit HTTP auf Google kommen gehe
werde ich dann auf eine SSL basierte Verbindung weitergeleitet. Grundsätzlich,
und ja, ich war jetzt die Tage zum Beispiel hier in äh im schönen England äh an einer Universität zu Gast, ja, wo ich dann ähm um dort Internet zu bekommen, weil's so mit den,
Mobilfunk irgendwie nicht so geil aussah, äh um einen Gastzugang äh zu ihrem WLAN. Ähm er fragte und dann musste ich erstmal so ein Formular ausfüllen.
Pipapo. Der übliche äh Schnaß und hier bringen sie keine Leute um und laden sie nichts böses runter und so weiter,
Ja und dann kriegt man halt da so seinen Code und dann fing ich halt irgendwie an, so das Netz zu besuchen und es dauerte dann irgendwie auch äh keine zwanzig Sekunden und dann hatte ich schon so die ersten äh
Fehlermeldungen. So, ja hier, wo willst du dich denn hier hin äh verbinden und was wollen wir überhaupt
sozusagen überhaupt keiner keine nachlässigen Tätigkeit gerade so gewahr und stellte dann halt fest, dass wenn man dann halt einfach
aus diesem Universitätsnetz irgendwie googelt, suche durchführen will
sofort ein ungültiges Zertifikat auf einmal präsentiert bekommt, also dass diese verschlüsselte Verbindung sozusagen zwar hergestellt wird offenbar, aber
Ja, dass die Absendeadresse auf einmal nicht stimmt und dann schalten wir mal kurz nach und stellt fest, dass irgendwie so Stern Google kommt, quasi neue Zertifikate verliehen bekommen hat von dieser
Universität
um das mal anders auszudrücken, was halt dort getan wird ist. Selbst wenn man da irgendwie verschlüsselt versucht aufs Netz zuzugreifen, dann wird da eben dazwischen gegangen, so mittelmäßig und dann so hier nun doch so unser Zertifikat,
vermutlich sind alle Rechner, die dort vor Ort sind, äh einfach schon mal die mit so einem Standardzertifikat.
Der Uni ausgestattet, so dass halt niemand bemerkt, dass selbst wenn man eine verschlüsselte Verbindung zu Google aufbaut, diese verschlüsselte Verbindung tatsächlich nicht zu Google äh ist, sondern eben nur zu der Firewall und ich unterstelle mal,
da auch dem entsprechenden Wortfilter und sonstige Analyse, Funktionalitäten des Universitätsnetzes.
Und das ist einerseits schon ein starkes Stück, zeigt aber eben auch, wie dringlich,
der Bedarf hier ist, ähm sowohl auf Anbieterseite als eben auch auf Nutzerseite dar, die Gitter hochzufahren.
Das äh zeigt übrigens auch, äh also du hast wahrscheinlich einfach nur das das äh Manuel nicht gelesen, in dem drin stand, dass du dieses Zertifikat for Rebetter Broting Experience installieren solltest.
Ja, genau. Ja, weil dann geht's auch alles viel besser und schneller, ne? Ja.
Also.
Genau. Ich habe das Memo nicht gelesen.
Schon wieder ab. Also Hacking Team ist gehackt, das ist äh das ist witzig. Das ist
ähm interessant. Das ist äh viele Wochen und Monate äh Rechercheaufwand, der da jetzt äh
zur Verfügung steht. Ähm viele Aktivistenseiten haben diesen gesamten Datenbestand gedammt. Man kann sich in den
Man kann sich äh in den Torant einklinken. Äh man findet da sehr viele schöne, interessante Sachen drin. Unter anderem zum Beispiel auch einen kleinen Trojaner, den man sich selber bauen kann. Zum Einsatz für die Freiheit. Dafür ist er ja gedacht. Ähm
Das ist also ähm das ist spannend. Ja, das ist jetzt schon äh ja,
werden und ich hoffe, dass natürlich diese Firma jetzt aus dem äh Geschäft gedrängt wird, denn da profitieren wir dann von. Ja, wie gesagt, das äh die deutschen Behörden haben da also auch in regen Austausch Austausch gestanden.
Und wie ich das schon seit langer Zeit auch immer wieder prognostiziert habe nach dem äh CCC-Hack.
Hausiert das BKA bei den äh Trojanerherstellern mit dem mit den äh,
Bundesverfassungsgericht Anforderungen an einen Staatstrojaner. Ähm.
Und will sie also dann dazu bringen, quasi so eine Leitvariante zu bauen und das sollte eben auch das war offenbar laut diesen E-Mails auch der Stand der Verhandlungen zwischen ähm,
den Vertretern der äh Scharfverfolgungsbehörden und dem Hacking Team hier und.
Da ist jetzt erstmal wieder ein Riegel vor. Das wäre natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit, diese ganze Staatstriana Geschichte zu stoppen, indem man einfach dafür sorgt, dass alle Hersteller solcher Systeme ähm,
im im Boden verschwinden. Zu dem Thema war übrigens auch die Konstanze Kurz für den Kaufcomputerclub,
in dieser Woche am,
Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe, wo über Staatstrojaner debattiert wurde, beziehungsweise über das,
BKA-Gesetz in seiner Fassung von zweitausendneun äh debattiert wurde. Da gibt's eine Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen.
Und die Konstanze war da als Sachverständige und hat sich insbesondere zu Fragen der äh Trojanisierung von Rechnern geäußert und ähm da geht es um im Kern um die Frage, dass du eben nicht.
System, das Zielsystem einfach infizieren kannst.
Und dabei rein passiv sein kannst, sondern ein Trojaner ist eben ein aktiver Eingriff, ähm der, welche, wie wir auch schon hier besprochen haben, zum Beispiel nach Dateien suchen kann, aber ja inhent auch in der Lage ist, Dateien zu schreiben,
denn anders könnte er das System ja nicht infizieren, ja? Das heißt, das System, das Zielsystem ist im Prinzip,
verliert in dem Moment, wo es von einem Trojaner befallen wird, jegliche Tauglichkeit als Beweismittel,
weil der Trojaner eben auch eine Veränderung sein kann. Anders ist es, wenn jemand reingeht, dein Computer beschlagnahmt,
die Festplatte kopiert und guckt was du da für Dateien drauf hast, ja? Da kann man also sagen, der forensische Analyst, der das jetzt irgendwie macht so, der ist irgendwie, ne? Beamter kriegt sein A dreizehn oder was und der wird da jetzt schon irgendwie seine ordentliche äh Analyse machen.
Bei einem Trojaner ist das inhärent,
ein nicht mehr Integeres, Informationstechnisches System. Es gibt dann übrigens auch Screenshots, die da auf Twitter kursieren. Mir hat bis jetzt leider die Zeit gefehlt, äh das genauer anzuschauen, wo.
So einen Codeausschnitt gezeigt wird, von dem behauptet wird,
er sei dazu geeignet, äh oder sogar dazu vorgesehen, ähm so verdächtiges Material auf dem Zielsystem zu positionieren,
Also irgendwie so
Kinderpornografie auf C oder so, um dann der Polizei einen Grund zu geben, den Computer zu beschlagnahmen oder so, dass äh dem Code habe ich bisher noch nicht nachgelesen und das, was ich da auf Twitter sehe, sieht
eher aus wie etwas sehr komisches, ja? Also das müsst ihr mir nochmal genau anschauen. Aber unabhängig davon, ob da jetzt,
Eine vorgesehene Funktion in diesem Trojaner ist Dateien äh zu positionieren oder ob das jetzt irgendwie ein ist von jemandem auf Twittern,
ist also grundsätzlich einem kompromittierten System äh nicht mehr zu trauen und hinzu kommt bei diesen Staatstrujanern eben, dass sie sehr viel mehr,
ufnehmen als sie.
Als eigentlich ihr gesetzlicher Einsatzzweck ist. Denn es gibt im Prinzip zwei Ebenen von Staatstroaner in der deutschen Begrifflichkeitstrennung, die suchen also einmal nach der nach dem.
Equivalent zur Quellen, Telekommunikationsüberwachung, wo sie also sagen, wir möchten,
verschlüsselte Kommunikation abhören können, also jemand schreibt seine E-Mails per PGP oder führt seine Telefonate per Skype. Da ist eine äh Verschlüsselung dran, auf die jetzt wir ohne Weiteres keinen Zugang haben.
Und dann möchten wir eben den Computer, von dem diese Kommunikation ausgeht, infizieren, um dann mitschneiden zu können, ja?
Schön und gut, grau ist alle Theorie, was machen sie also, du schreibst deine E-Mail, sie machen dabei Screenshots
So, sie wissen aber vorher nicht, dass du eine E-Mail schreibst. Das heißt, sie machen einfach die ganze Zeit Screenshots. Und dann äh machen sie also Screenshots, wenn du gerade irgendwie so in anderen Bereichen des Internets unterwegs bist, ähm dann machen sie Screenshots während du irgendwie, was weiß ich, Fotos
private Fotos durchschaust, die du nicht auf Flicker hochlädst oder deinen Online-Tagebuch schreibst oder sonst was. Ähm.
Erstmal Full Take.
Full take, ja? Oder sie machen das Mikrofon an dem Computer an, um zu gucken, was du sprichst. Das heißt, damit sind sie dann im Bereich der
Wohnraum Überwachung ja? Dass da also dann schon wieder im Bereich des großen Lauschangriffes, was eben wieder was anderes ist. Ähm das heißt, dieser Bereich der Quellen-TKÜ ähm
der lässt sich also.
Das, was man quasi, sie suchen das Äquivalent zu Telefon abhören und das ist eben bei einem Computer als Universalgerät eben nicht möglich.
Und genau aus diesem Grunde ist dann eben auch der der digital Trojaner eben verfassungswidrig gewesen und genau das sind aber jetzt die Vorgaben, mit denen sie jetzt wieder rumrennen und sagen, wir müssen.
Uns irgendwie was bauen lassen.
Beigeht ja nicht, dass wir da nicht reingucken können.
Genau, dann könnte ja jeder kommen. Äh genau, also da gibt's den dann ein zu erwartendes Urteil, Konstanze da nochmal sehr schön dargelegt, äh welche Argumente eben für Staatstrojaner sprechen. Der Text ist ein,
Es gab sicherlich von Konstanze schon strukturiertere äh,
Jetzt muss ich mal ganz kurz gucken, Stellungnahmen, aber sie hat sie wurde sehr, sehr kurzfristig ähm.
Da eingeladen und ich meine, so eine Einladung nach Karlsruhe vors Bundesverfassungsgericht geht dann eben so mit mit fünfundzwanzig Zentimeter Aktenordnern einher und irgendwie zwanzig komischen
Fragen, die man irgendwie beantworten muss und da hat sie also in sehr kurzer Zeit unter sehr viel Stress eine,
sehr umfassende Stellungnahme abgegeben, die es eben auch auf CCC DE zum zum Download gibt.
Genau. Wir verlinken wie es unsere Art ist.
Verlinken. Genau, um das noch kurz zu Ende zu finden, also es gibt einmal die Quellen,
Überwachung, QuellentKÜ, Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung und dann noch den Begriff der online Durchsuchung, da stellen sie sich also sowas vor wie, ne, äh dein dein Haus durchsuchen, ne? Da dürfen sie ja dann auch überall rein, ne?
Ähm das wären also so die zwei Arten von Staatstrojaner, die sie sich da so jetzt äh vorstellen.
Online-Besucher hat eben auch das Problem, dass äh wenn jemand meine Wohnung durchsucht, dann werde ich das wenigste, werde ich wenigstens darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt, ja. Also bilde ich mir zumindest ein, vielleicht auch nicht.
Gut.
Ja, wo wir so viel über äh über Spionage und Gegenspionage sprechen, ne, und übernose Abkommen und über Verfassungsbrüche und über das Abhören von Journalisten,
und über das Abhören von Freunden, das geht ja gar nicht, aber irgendwie doch.
Und über äh Zusammenarbeit mit der CIA und das Teilen von Selektorenlisten und das Liegen von Sektorenlisten auf. Wiki Leaks,
und Amerikanern, die sich über uns Schrott lachen, weil wir uns das alles gefallen lassen, während wir in Wirklichkeit äh mit ihnen kooperieren als deutsche Bundesregierung. Da ist natürlich
sonnenklar, was man als nächstes macht. Man baut die Kompetenzen und die Ausstattung der Geheimdienste aus. Ja.
Insbesondere im Hinblick auf die auf das fundamental Versagen des äh Bundesamt der der Bundesämter,
des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz und der Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz bei den NSU-Morden, wo wir ja
neunzehn Anschläge hatten, wenn ich wenn ich da jetzt spontan mich richtig erinnere, innerhalb von Deutschland, die nicht verhindert wurden, auch die hat der Pofalla in seiner Darstellung offensichtlich unterschlagen. Das äh sei ihm verziehen, denn die
Opfer der NSU-Morde wurden ja hier jahrelang als,
ausländische Bandenkriminelle dargestellt, äh nachdem sie von Nazis ermordet wurden.
Insofern ist es dem Pofalla natürlich zu verzeihen, dass er das äh dass er die nicht wirklich als Anschlagsopfer zählt. Ähm.
Als Belohnung für dieses Vollversagen
muss man dem den Geheimdienst natürlich mehr Geld geben. Und das das ist natürlich auch völlig klare Logik. Ich meine, wenn sie die NSU-Morde nicht
äh verhindern konnten, weil sie zu zu sehr mit ihren V-Personen beschäftigt sind und so, dann muss man denen natürlich mehr Geld geben und bessere Möglichkeiten
mit mit Vorpersonen zu arbeiten, weil,
Daran muss es ja wahrscheinlich gelegen haben. Wenn der wenn der Geheimdienst erfolgreich ist, dann muss man ihm natürlich Geld geben, um diesen Erfolg auszubauen. Das heißt, bei Geheimdiensten gibt es einfach keine Argumente, Verkürzungen, die man irgendwo ähm
unterbringen könnte und deswegen werden deren Rechte immer weiter ausgebaut und deswegen kriegen die immer mehr Geld äh und immer mehr Mitarbeiter und immer mehr Rechte, ja?
Dieses Mal hat der Bundestag also beschlossen, mit den Stimmen von CDU und SPD.
Dass das Nachrichtendienstliche Informationssystem der Staatsschutzbehörden vom Bund und Ländern äh ausgebaut wird,
Bisher gab es dann nur einen Index. Und jetzt sollen sie darin.
Volltextdateien, vier beliebig speichern, austauschen und auswerten können.
Also früher gab's irgendwie nur so einen Index, wo man mal rein konnte. Und jetzt äh gibt's da einfach mal alles und irgendwie ohne nennenswerte Speicherbegrenzung so. Da machen sie jetzt so eine richtig schöne großes nachrichtendienstliches Informationssystem für die äh,
inneren Geheimdienste, ja? Äh.
Aber, weil sie das ja so auswerten, müssen die Zugriffe jetzt protokolliert werden. Früher durften alle einfach so darauf zugreifen, jetzt wird eine Logdatei geschrieben
was äh von den Kritikern
nicht zu Unrecht als eine das ist ja ein Witz, ja, dass da jemals jemand einfach so drauf zugreifen konnte, äh ist eigentlich der Skandal.
Wirklich unglaublich.
Äh erweitern sie die Befugnisse des BND zur strategischen Fernmeldeüberwachung. Der BND soll die strategische Fernmeldeüberwachung jetzt auch zum Zwecke der äh,
Erkennung und Abwendung von Cybergefahren äh zum Einsatz bringen können,
und natürlich wollen sie sich irgendwie das äh mit den V-Leuten mal anschauen. Da haben sie gesagt, ja das ist soll auf jeden Fall weiterhin ausgiebig möglich sein, an einigen Stellen sogar ein bisschen einfacher. Aber, ne, Personen mit gewichtigen Vorstrafen.
Mörder.
Ja, Gewalttäter, ja.
Dürfen, dürfen nur dann aufgenommen werden.
Wenn es für die Aufklärung gefährlicher Bestrebung unerlässlich ist. Das ist übrigens interessant, da fällt mir gerade was ein. Ähm.
Da hatte der Andre vor einigen Wochen mir schon auch mal äh nochmal eine kleine Korrektur gegeben, die ich hier in der Sendung noch gar nicht gebracht hatte. Unerlässlich heißt,
in diesem juristischen Bereich absolut notwendig. Also das heißt, es darf keinen anderen, keine andere Möglichkeit geben. Dienlich.
Ähm heißt, kann man machen ohne Grund.
Aber quasi so notwendig, unerlässlich und dienlich ist da, glaube ich, so die Abstehvorstufung. Und das heißt also, in Juristensprech auch wirklich was.
Ja? Also es muss notwendig sein oder in diesem Fall sogar unerlässlich sein. Also nur, wenn es wirklich unerlässlich ist, dürfen wir in Zukunft Mörder,
und Totschläger, als als V-Leute nehmen. Aber so kleinere Straftaten.
Ähm wie zum Beispiel bei einer Demonstration sein Gesicht unkenntlich machen.
Das lassen wir weiterhin durch.
So die die typischen Verbrechen linker, ne? Gehen zu einer Demo und verhüllen ihr Gesicht. Ist ja in Deutschland eine Straftat. Äh dass die können durchaus noch V-Leute werden,
ja
sonstige Kriminelle sowieso und die Totschläger und Mörder ja nur in Ausnahme muss dann schon wirklich ein guten Grund geben. Das ist also auch 'ne sehr tolle sehr tolle,
Reform diese in der kriminellen Szene tief verwurzelten Personen, die noch dazu vorbestraft sind, dann noch äh auf die Gehaltsliste des Staates zu stellen.
De Maizire sagt dazu, wir entwickeln den gesetzlichen Rahmen mit Maß und Mitte fort. Aha.
Mit Mitte auch, jetzt auch mit Mitte.
Ja, Mitte ist er ja sowieso. Wo meint Maisia ist es ja Mitte CDU ist es ja Mitte, alles andere ist ja extrem. CDU ist Mitte, alles andere ist links oder rechtsextrem, wollen wir nicht bäh.
Ähm.
Auch die SPD oder was?
Und er feiert, ne, bei der SPD ist andersrum, ne, hast du ja gelesen, ne? Sigmar Gabriel, äh schließt also eine Zusammenarbeit mit der CDU CSU zweitausendsiebzehn aus, weil das bei denen zu links sind.
Stimmt.
In dem es hier feiert sogar noch als Konsequenz aus dem kollektiven Versagen der Verfassungsschutzbehörden werde das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz als Zentralstelle gestärkt.
Als Konsequenz aus dem kollektiven Versagen, ja? Wir erinnern uns, das sind die,
Ämter und Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz, wo als die NSU-Morde plötzlich auf der Agenda standen, die Schredder überhitzt sind, ne? Das sind die Behörden, ja,
Die haben da ohne Ende die Schredder warm gehabt. Die wussten, die haben die sind in den Mediamarkt gerannt und haben den letzten Schredder aufgekauft, weil die irgendwie Massenschreddern da mussten, so.
Die sind das die, deren äh deren Rechte jetzt hier erweitert wurden, ne. Da könnte man, gibt's gibt's da vielleicht eigentlich einen Podcast drüber über diese ganze
NSU-Sache. Ich weiß, da gab's ja sehr ausführliche Berichte. Diese NSU-Geschichte ist so ein riesiger Clusterfuck, dass eigentlich keine Sau das überhaupt noch alles aufarbeiten kann. Da werden, glaube ich, irgendwie so so.
Äh epische,
Berichte zu geschrieben, das ist also das ist ein das ist ein Fuckup, den kann man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Ja und wie gesagt, endete am Ende alles im Schredder, weil sie die Beweise vernichten mussten. Das sind die, die also jetzt hier mehr Rechte bekommen haben. Äh im,
ausspähen, der äh eigenen Bevölkerung. Das ist doch mal schön.
Ja, da wird mal für den ganzen Scheißdreck auch noch belohnt ne. Das ist halt irgendwie der Wahnsinn. Und das ist man ist jetzt auch nichts Neues. Das war bisher schon immer so und ähm.
Weiß auch nicht mehr genau, was man dazu noch sagen äh kann. Äh die Idee mit dem Podcast für NSU finde ich übrigens gut. Ähm.
Ist ein bisschen spät jetzt, also.
Bisschen spät leider, aber kann man ja so äh nochmal aufgreifen.
Ja, ich meine, das war ja dann auch so im Nachgang, ne, dass man das jetzt dann einfach nochmal alles näher bringt, so als Hörbuch quasi.
Ja, jetzt läuft's. Jetzt läuft's, läuft's.
Maß und Mitte.
Maß und Mitte, ja.
Herrn Mitte habe ich noch nichts gehört.
Erzähl mir mal einen von von Begrifflichkeiten, ne. Na ja, du wolltest äh was aus Argentinien erzählen. Da wurde jemand verhaftet.
Ja, ja. Argentinien. Ja, die Story äh also es geht um Wahlcomputer.
Äh Wahlcomputer.
Befürchte wir hatten das Thema hier irgendwie noch nicht, weil die Niederschlagung dieses Trends in in Deutschland und in äh Niederlande war irgendwie so ein bisschen vor der Geburt dieses Podcasts. Und äh ich glaube, so recht ähm,
oder? Ich glaube, wir hatten das hier irgendwie noch nie so richtig aufm Tisch.
Nicht so wirklich. Wir haben es vielleicht mal am Rande erwähnt, aber es war noch kein Kernthema.
Genau, es war kein Kernthema. Jetzt ist bisschen was passiert und man merkt dann immer wieder so oh hoppala, andere Länder äh probieren das ja immer noch mit diesem Wahlcomputern. Das scheint ja auch irgendwie so, das ist auch, glaube ich, so ein so ein Ding.
Das das wird auch immer wieder kommen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung, hat aber nochmal so eine andere Tönung. Es ist so dieses ähm.
Also je nachdem, was man den den Politikern da äh unterstellen möchte oder sollte.
Äh ich glaube, es gibt so zwei Motivationen, die die Leute oder die Politiker speziell dazu bringt, Wahlcomputer zu fordern. Ja, das eine ist so ein bisschen dieser Verwerfliche Ansatz mit, na ja, äh,
da kann man bestimmt besser mit bescheißen,
war salopp gesagt. Ja, das wäre, sagen wir mal, jetzt auch ein nachvollziehbares Motiv und es weniger nachvollziehbare Motiv ist, modern sein.
Das ist ja also das, was auch die ganze Debatte in Deutschland immer wieder äh begleitet, dass man das ja für unglaublich modern erachtet,
irgendwie damit, also mal auf einmal will man da wieder mit der Zeit gehen, ne? Also das ist ja auch so diese Generation, die uns eigentlich im Prinzip die ganze Zeit mit so einer Zukunftsverweigerung nervt, aber dann ausgerechnet, wenn's jetzt um wählen geht,
da muss es jetzt dann unbedingt
äh direkt in die Science-Fiction einsteigen, weil sie sich eben davon versprechen, dass dann auf einmal sie alle wieder lieb haben oder oder dass dann auch noch, dass jeder dann auf einmal wählt,
Problem wäre ja eigentlich nur die Faulheit und äh äh wenn wählen ja noch einfacher wäre, dann dann würden ja dann endlich wieder alle mitspielen und wir hätten unsere Demokratie wieder. Also das ist so ein bisschen diese, die da äh immer wieder aufgezogen wird.
Und in dem Zuge äh wurden ja dann bei uns auch immer wieder Wahlcomputer gefordert und teilweise eben auch eingeführt und dann vor ein paar Jahren,
vorerst vernichtend geschlagen. Zu den.
Gründen, warum äh ich das auch als sehr angemessen äh finde. Vielleicht später noch. Lenken wir mal den, den Blick auf
Argentinien, also Argentinien ist jetzt bei Lawine nicht das einzige Land, sondern es gibt da äh mehrere. Ich denke, wenn man jetzt mal die Liste aller Länder durchgehen würde, würden wir wahrscheinlich auch eine ja, eine richtig lange Liste von haben, die tatsächlich bei Computer mindestens erwägen, wenn nicht sogar auch
einsetzen auf die andere Art und Weise. Sprich, eine papierbasierte Wahl.
Durch den Einsatz von elektronischen Maßnahmen und Geräten irgendwie anders durchführen wollen.
Ähm Venezuela ist da zum Beispiel zu nennen, fällt mir äh ein Indien und teilweise haben die Länder ja auch einen Punkt, in dem sie halt sagen, na ja, wir haben so ein Problem mit äh schwer zu erreichenden Gegenden, et cetera
Wir können uns halt einfach den Aufbau so einer ähm,
umfassenden Wahlkabineninfrastruktur im ganzen Land nicht so leisten und wir denken halt, wir können's damit irgendwie besser machen. Also es mag auch durchaus noch Leute geben, die das einfach so aus Prozedere-Erwägungen, dass da noch dem was Positives abgewinnen können, das will ich jetzt auch nicht unterschlagen an der Stelle,
Gibt also drei Motivationen.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt schon glaube, dass äh auch die Motivation eins, ja, nämlich äh bescheißen wird einfacher, äh durchaus auch eine Rolle spielt,
es sollte sich mittlerweile auch herumgesprochen haben, dass das eben nämlich dann auch echt mal gut geht. So, kommen wir zu Argentinien. Was ist passiert? Also.
Warte vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz, ganz kurz auf Anhieb,
erscheint aber doch die Idee, sich dieses ganze Auszählen zu vereinfachen mit dem Papier und so da nicht rumzustehen und das alles mal mit dem Computer zu machen
die klingt doch auf Anhieb gar nicht so blöd. Vielleicht sollten wir noch erklären, warum das so ein Problem ist.
Ja, also äh klingt nicht so doof. Äh das setzt immer so ein bisschen voraus.
Dass irgendjemand ein Problem ausgemacht hätte, was ein echtes Problem äh ist. Ja, also es wird zum Beispiel unterstellt, Wahlen werden kompliziert durchzuführen oder äh würden lange dauern.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, wann du das letzte Mal versucht hast, ähm einer Wahl spannend,
beizuwohnen, ja, eine Auszählung. Äh ich erinnere mich so in den,
achtziger Jahren, da war das dann so, da war dann so Bundestagswahl oder eine Landtagswahl, da konnte man noch so richtig noch so eine Party machen und ab achtzehn Uhr wurde dann so, naja, ein bisschen äh gefiebert und dann so irgendwo so gegen zweiundzwanzig Uhr kamen dann so äh die ersten Anzeichen von von fertigen Hochrechnungen
die so in etwa das Ergebnis voraussagten, was dann wahrscheinlich am nächsten Morgen äh auch wirklich bestätigt wird.
Die Zeiten sind schon lange vorbei. Eigentlich ist kurz nach achtzehn Uhr schon irgendwie weitgehend alles klar, spätestens nach einer Stunde ist das Ding irgendwie durch. Eine Auszählung an sich geht schnell. Aber weil du jetzt schon nach dem grundsätzlichen gefragt hast,
Schauen wir doch mal, was haben wir jetzt. Wir haben ein System, wo man in eine Wahlkabine äh also erstmal in ein Wahllokal geht
dort muss man sich authentifizieren und äh weist nach, dass man halt in einer Liste steht in dieser Liste steht man
mehr oder weniger automatisch, wenn man einfach als Einwohner dort mit seinem Hauptwohnsitz gemeldet ist, dann kann man das halt mit seinem Ausweis schnell nachweisen, dass man auch diese Person ist und dann kriegt man einen Wahlzettel. Damit geht man in eine Wahlkabine
und dort darf man dann unbeobachtet äh sein Kreuz machen. Ähm.
Diese Methode stellt schon verschiedene Anforderungen für eine Wahl äh sicher. Nämlich eine Wahl soll äh unter anderem geheim ablaufen,
Das ist in der Wahlkabine der Fall. Niemand kann mich dort äh beobachten, vorausgesetzt da sind keine Kameras installiert
sie soll frei sein, das heißt niemand darf mich bei der bei der Wahl sozusagen in dem Moment beeinflussen, ich muss irgendwie freien Geistes sein, unbeeinflusst sein und möchte dort meine Stimme abgeben.
Und ich möchte das halt dann auch äh dass eben diese Stimme auch äh garantiert äh gezählt wird. Danach werfe ich die ja in eine Box, also in die in die Wahlurne,
weiß, dass sie dann da drin ist. Und dieser.
Ist versiegelt, die.
Die Urne ist versiegelt und vor allem sie wird beobachtet, also in diesem Wahllokal sind ja einerseits die bestellten Wahlhelfer,
die das diesen Prozess durchführen und theoretisch, das wird nicht überall der Fall sein, aber es ist eben auch machbar und sagen wir mal umso brenzliger eine politische Situation aufgeladen ist, umso wahrscheinlicher ist es,
können,
alle Menschen können dort die Wahl beobachten. Also wenn du gerne die Wahl beobachten möchtest, dann kannst du einfach in irgendein Wahllokal reingehen und du kannst da wirklich bis die Tür äh abgeschlossen wird, das Licht ausgeschaltet wird, anwesend sein und jeder,
Prozess ist an der Stelle ähm öffentlich überprüfbar,
Die Wahlurne wird nämlich dann um achtzehn Uhr geschlossen und dann aufm Tisch ausgeklebt, so dass
alle sehen können, dass auch alle dort enthaltenen Zettel tatsächlich äh gezählt werden oder zumindest erstmal vorsortiert werden
dann äh kann man eben auch sicherstellen, dass dann eben auch nichts verloren geht, dass also wirklich alle dabei sind. Und man kann diesen Zetteln auch nicht mehr ansehen,
wer sie da reingeworfen hat. Weil es halt keinerlei äh Informationen gibt, wer sie reingeschmissen hat.
Genau, trotzdem kann man aber dann hingehen und die Zettel nochmal zählen.
Genau und das kann man auch mehrfach machen. Genau, man kann sie dann halt zählen, das ist irgendwie öffentlich und man kann anderen Leuten dabei zuschauen
wie das Ganze von statten geht und am Ende wird halt einfach ein Ergebnis,
geliefert. Das kann man sich dann halt merken und wenn man irgendwie am nächsten Tag feststellt, dass von dem Wahllokal ja eine ganz andere äh Information weiter übermittelt wurde, dann kann man dann entsprechend Protest einlegen. Also mit anderen Worten,
Das geht schnell,
es ist es erfüllt alle Anforderungen, es ist technisch sehr unauffällig, es ist verhältnismäßig billig, das alles durchzuführen, weil im Wesentlichen braucht man nur einen Raum, ein paar Leute und Zettel und Bleistifte,
oder Kugelschreiber und, und, und, irgendwie, so eine kleine Kabine und das war's eigentlich.
Ja und vor allem dieser Prozess ist absolut transparent überprüfbar und äh was ja dann auch häufig unterstellt wird, äh er ist halt auch verhältnismäßig fälschungssicher
Natürlich gab es immer mal wieder Versuche,
eine Wahl zu beeinflussen. Natürlich ist es möglich, dass wenn da jetzt keine freiwilligen Wahlbeobachter da sind und alle Leute, die dann ausgewählt sind, sind irgendwie in so einer kleinen Verschwörung das tatsächlich von einem Wahllokal, mal die Ergebnisse äh
signifikant auch abweichen können von der tatsächlichen Wahl, die da durchgeführt wurde. Alles machbar.
Was aber auf gar keinen Fall machbar ist, äh ist,
eine so umfangreiche Verschwörung zu inszenieren, die eben jetzt über mehrere Wahllokale hinweg eine kontinuierliche Änderung äh des des eigentlichen Wahlergebnisses herbeiführt. Weil der Aufwand äh äh das durchzuführen, der,
der wäre einfach enorm, beziehungsweise ist halt einfach auch faktisch äh einfach nicht durchführbar. Aus den vor äh abgenannten.
Das ist das Wahlsystem, was wir haben,
Und es ist gut, das erfüllt aller Anforderungen, ist billig und es ist schnell. Weil die Zettel sind halt schnell durchgezählt. So ein Wahllokal ist nicht so groß. Das sind so ein paar hundert Zettel, die zählt man halt durch. Wenn man Zweifel hat, zählt man sie zweimal durch. Stunde später ist das Ding irgendwie fettig,
Anruf, hier ist unser Ergebnis, die versiegelte Urne,
mit den äh Dingern, geht dann irgendwie in die Zentrale und äh das ist alles noch über Tage hinweg komplett nachprüfbar,
Und äh alles ist super. Die Vöglein singen. Alles wird gut. Dann kommen aber Leute und meinen so, ah.
Da gibt es jetzt ein Problem, ja? Und dann dann werden so Probleme genannt wie das ist nicht schnell genug.
Kann ich irgendwie nicht feststellen, dass da irgendwas nicht äh schnell genug ist. Wunderbar, schnell. Ja, ist an einem Abend in paar Stunden ist es irgendwie gegessen.
Oder es würde eben so Betrugspotential bieten. Wie gesagt, auf lokaler Ebene sehr wohl, systematisch auf keinen Fall
Ja, also es ist einfach ein gut abgehangenes äh System, was wunderbar funktioniert und es ist vor allem halt auch billig.
Das heißt auch so Argumente wie, na ja, man muss ja jetzt irgendwas automatisieren, damit's irgendwie billiger wird oder schlanker et cetera äh ist auch Quatsch. Und wir alle wissen auch schon
wenn's um Computer geht, dann wird's eben auch schnell, sehr teuer. Trotz alledem.
Gibt's ja die kostenlosen Wahlhelfer, ne? Ist ja ein Ehrenamt eigentlich, was man macht, ne?
Es gibt da eine, eine, eine sogenannte, wie heißt das, äh Sättigungsbeilage, würde ich jetzt fast sagen, also irgend so ein Verzehr. Klar, das ist jetzt nicht, nicht viel Geld, aber äh wenn's äh sagen wir mal so,
Wenn wir wirklich auf einmal das Problem hätten, dass wir nicht mehr genug Wahlhelfer bekommen. Also wenn das wirklich das Problem unseres demokratischen Systems ist,
dann könnte man einfach mal diese diese Bezahlpauschale mal verdoppeln und und und der Drops ist gelutscht und die und die Gesamtkosten mögen zwar steigen, aber sie sind immer noch jenseits davon die die Kosten äh
jenseits von den Kosten, die verursacht werden, wenn man versucht, das Ganze mit Technologie zu erschlagen.
Okay und wenn wir, wenn wir es aber jetzt trotzdem versuchen wollen, ein ein Computer zu bauen, ne, also kann man ja relativ kann man sich ja so vorstellen, irgendwie steht ein Computer, ne, der wird quasi freigeschaltet für einen
Wahlvorgang, ne, in dem Moment, wo der Wahlbeobachter sieht, da kommt jetzt jemand oder du schleifst deinen äh E-Perso da durch, ja oder sowas, ne? Dann sagt er so, jetzt darf,
Person X äh oder jetzt darf eine Wahl getätigt werden. Dann wird das zum Beispiel, muss ja einerseits,
Wenn schon denn schon, du machst ja alles elektronisch, das heißt, du führst zum Beispiel einen Lock darüber, wer äh wählen gekommen ist und wer nicht, ja, hätte es ja sonst auch. Das äh Problem ist
in dem Computer könntest du jetzt zum Beispiel speichern wann welche Wahl abgegeben wurde. Das heißt, du könntest eigentlich über die Reihenfolge der abgegebenen Wahlen zum Beispiel wiederherstellen, äh wer
äh wäre was gewählt hat. Das heißt, du musst dir ein Programm schreiben, was einerseits halt guckt, okay, einerseits sich fest identifiziert.
Sicherstellt, dass du nur einmal wählst und dann dieses Wahlding, aber quasi fernab von all dieser,
von deiner persönlichen Information von dem Zeitpunkt der Wahl, einfach nur zählt,
Es wurde gewählt, ja. Und am Ende auf Knopfdruck sagt, was weiß ich, so und so viel Stimmen für den so und so viel Stimmen, für den so und so viel Stimmen, für den.
Das Problem ist, durch die Notwendigkeit der Anonymisierung aller Informationen, die der Computer speichern muss, damit die Wahl nämlich geheim ist.
Zerstört man in dem papierlosen Wahlverfahren die Möglichkeit, nachvollziehbar zu sein. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo der Computer,
nicht, also der Computer darf nicht nachweisen können, woher die Stimme kommt,
das wäre automatisch eine Information, die eventuell Rückschlüsse auf mich als Wähler gibt. Also.
Auch nicht nachweisen, dass die Stimme überhaupt abgegeben wurde.
Und somit ist quasi der äh ist in einem Informationsverarbeitenden System, dass die äh vollständige Anonymität,
Wahlvorganges sicherstellt, der die Möglichkeit der Nachzahl, der Nachzählung und der Dokumentation in der Form nicht gegeben,
Und da gab's dann,
noch dazu, dass die medienwirksamen Beispiele, wo eben gezeigt wurde, diese Computer wurden,
gehackt, gab's in Deutschland und in den USA Gruppen, die das gezeigt haben, in Deutschland vom CCC, wo dann gesagt wurde,
winkt und will mich jetzt unterbrechen, ich rede aber trotzdem noch kurz meinen Satz zu Ende. Ähm,
wo dann gezeigt wurde, okay, man kann da auch ein Schachprogramm drauf installieren. Ähm bei anderen, äh bei den US-Aktivisten, die haben dann einfach den Computer so umprogrammiert, dass er halt die,
äh eine systematische Verzerrung in den Wahlergebnissen herbeigeführt hat. Und da hat ihr jede dritte Stimme falsch zu Gunsten eines bestimmten Kandidaten gezählt hat. Und ein in dieser Form manipulierter Wahlcomputer
Kann man wiederum die Manipulation nicht nachweisen, weil er die ja wiederum verstecken könnte.
Also man kann,
Ich habe jetzt deshalb ein bisschen gewunken, weil man kann jetzt hier stundenlang, tausend Beispiele, von was vielleicht ein Computer falsch machen könnte oder richtig machen könnte und wie das dann im Einzelnen was für Auswirkungen hat, äh aufzählen und es ist eine endlose Geschichte.
Ja, aber nur diese Argumente sind die entscheidenden, wenn man sich dagegen wendet.
Na ja, ich will's mal mit einer anderen Betrachtung äh probieren. Haben wir jetzt diesen, diesen Vorgang des Papiersystems irgendwie beschrieben? Und denke.
Also der Vorteil von diesem System ist, das versteht jeder. Also,
jeder im Sinne von, jeder, der so, so halbwegs mit so einer Grundintelligenz gesegnet ist, versteht A wie das funktioniert und er versteht auch, warum das sichergestellt ist, dass es hier keine Zuordnung zur Person geben kann,
die wichtig ist, dann sonst ist die Wahl nicht frei, wenn jemand weiß, was ich gewählt habe, bin ich nicht mehr frei in meiner Entscheidung
ja, dass sie äh geheim stattgefunden hat und äh für alle die gleichen Bedingungen gelten. Das ist einfach in diesem Papierwahlsystem einfach inneremt und das ist vor allem auch für jeden,
nachvollziehbar. Und das Auszählen ist auch vollständig überprüfbar und der Überprüfungsvorgang selber.
Auch für jeden vollständig verständlich. Also jeder versteht auch, warum diese Überprüfung,
stattfinden äh äh kann und warum sie effizient ist und warum sie richtig ist am Ende. Das ist einfach äh ein ein goldenes System, was hier gefunden wurde. Wenn man jetzt mit Computern anguckt,
Hat man das Problem, dass das Zählen sowohl das Wahrnehmen einer Wahl,
als eben auch das Auszählen dieser Stimmen,
in einem Computer stattfindet. Und wenn man auch nur ansatzweise dieselbe Nachvollziehbarkeit haben will, wie bei diesem Papierwahlsystem.
Müsste man im Computer sein,
Man müsste in diesen Computer sein und man müsste in der Lage sein, zu jedem Zeitpunkt jede einzelne Maßnahme dieses Computers
nachvollziehen zu können. Man müsste quasi eine holistischen, parallelen Echtzeitblick auf alles haben, was dieser Computer zu jedem Zeitpunkt tut,
Denn sonst kann es einfach keine Möglichkeit geben, das zu beobachten. Und das ist halt einfach unmöglich,
Es ist halt einfach unmöglich, einem Computer bei der Arbeit zuzuschauen.
Und das muss man sich erstmal vergegenwärtigen, dass eigentlich die Diskussion um Wahlcomputer an dieser Stelle bereits beendet ist,
bevor man auf irgendeines dieser anderen Details, was noch vielleicht irgendwie passieren könnte, äh hinkommt. Es ist einfach nicht möglich, einem Computer bei der Arbeit zuzuschauen.
Und das disqualifiziert diese elektronischen Systeme. Grundsätzlich,
Wenn man sich das einmal anschaut, was halt auch äh dann eben auch noch tatsächlich getan wird, ja, jenseits dieser einfachen Erkenntnis, dann äh rollen sich einmal echt die Fußnägel hoch. Und äh dieses Ding, das kann man vielleicht mal auf diese argentinische Geschichte, das tut wirklich echt geil. Also,
das Ganze ist noch relativ neu, also Wahlcomputer gab's da bis vor kurzem noch nicht,
Bist halt mal irgendwie einem wieder äh jemand gemeint hat, wir müssen jetzt hier in die Moderne aufbrechen und überhaupt und die anderen haben das ja auch. Äh im neunten Dezember zwanzig dreizehn wurde dort äh das Gesetz viertausendachthundertvierundneunzig irgendwie, keine Ahnung was, worauf sich diese Zahl bezieht
vielleicht sind die einfach alle durch nummeriert wurde sozusagen beschlossen na ja man könnte ja mal hier,
Unser System, das Boleta Unika äh könnte man ja mal ähm.
Um die Möglichkeit eines Electronic Voting Systems ergänzen.
Aber ähm so lautet dieser Beschluss, bevor man das dann auch tut, äh müsste man zwei Drittel des Parlaments aber auch nochmal zustimmen lassen, weil es ist ja nun wirklich ein,
eine Maßnahme, die nicht ganz äh konsequenzfrei ist. Ja, äh zu dieser Abstimmung kam's dann aber irgendwie nicht so richtig,
Ähm stattdessen hat man dann gesagt, naja, wir nennen das jetzt äh einfach anders, ja, äh wir nennen das irgendwie Boleta, Unika, Elektroniker und äh da das ja nicht Elektronik Voting System heißt, müsste man jetzt auch nicht mehr zustimmen.
So funktioniert da Demokratie in äh Argentinien,
und dann wurden irgendwie gleich äh Computersysteme angeschafft, mit denen man jetzt ganz toll elektronisch wählen kann, äh Touchscreen-Systeme.
Das wird die abenteuerlich. Also.
In Deutschland war das ja zumindest noch so, dass die Computer, die hier zuerst zum Einsatz kommt, das war noch so richtig alte.
Alte, abgehangene, einfache Computertechnik, ja. Heutzutage wird also sozusagen auch gleich mit dem Totschläger äh äh losgewedelt mit,
vollen PCs mit mit allem Ding Dong, was man sich nur vorstellen kann, tausend Interfaces, Touchscreen-Systeme, Bildschirme, die irgendwie alle Informationen abstrahlen et cetera, also abhörbar auch in jeder Form, ohne dass da irgendeiner drüber nachdenkt,
Argentinien hat auch jetzt echt nochmal einen,
obendrauf gesetzt und sich auch noch ein RFID basiertes WL-System, also dein dein Wahlschein ist sozusagen auch noch äh mit RFIDs ausgestattet,
also mit Funkchips. Wunderbar. Ich hatte jetzt nicht zu viel Zeit mir das im äh einzelnen anzuschauen, aber von der Beschreibung, die ich gefunden habe,
kriegt man halt irgendwie da so einen äh basiertes Teil. Da ist irgendwie eine Nummer drauf, ähm gedruckt und dann,
gibt man aber tatsächlich halt im im Wahllokal wird das irgendwie so in zwei Teile aufgeteilt und dann geht man mit seinem Teil irgendwie zu diesen äh Computer und muss sich dann quasi dann mit diesen Dingen äh authensieren gegenüber diesem Computer und sagen hier hallo, ich bin das,
Ich darf jetzt hier wählen mit so einem RFID-Chip sozusagen, womit man sich schon mal auch gegenüber dem Computer eindeutig identifiziert et cetera, all diese ganzen äh Probleme, die wir jetzt anfangs schon angesprochen haben, schlagen hier voll durch.
Und äh ja, die Maschine zählt das dann halt einfach so magisch. Das heißt, deine Stimme ist,
auf einmal Daten geworden und befindet sich in diesem Computer und und und ja die Quantenmechanik verhindert es halt einfach, dass man da irgendwie in der Lage ist,
zuzuschauen. Ähm.
Ja und dann äh geht man halt irgendwie wieder nach Hause und äh freut sich. Natürlich gab's jetzt einige Leute, die das irgendwie alles ein bisschen äh fragwürdig fanden. Es gab da viel äh Debatten. Tatsächlich ist vor ein paar Wochen aber eine Wahl damit gelaufen,
Und äh jetzt ist es allerdings so weit gekommen, dass äh dann tatsächlich der,
Sourscode von diesen äh System geliebt wurde,
und äh mittlerweile wohl auch auf äh Gittap äh gelandet ist und man sich halt mal genauer angeschaut hat, na ja, was äh ist denn da jetzt eigentlich.
So, stellte sich raus, dass das äh ganz normale Lähnungssysteme sind, um bunte Systeme, wo da so ein Peißen-Programm von der eingelegten DVD gebudet wird,
Die Firma, die das gebaut hat, heißt MSA und ähm formulierte halt gleich irgendwie rum. Na ja, das wären ja alles nur irgendwie Drucker
und so, das wäre ja gar keine richtigen äh Computer, sehr viel mehr würden die machen, da ja nicht machen, weil man kriegt sozusagen auch noch so einen Beleg ausgedruckt auf so einen Thermodrucker, ganz modern
Ja, da hast du ja vorhin schon erwähnt, die Sache mit dem Schachcomputerhack, das war ja dann hier auch so äh der Versuch von der Wahlcomputerfirma da aus äh Holland zu behaupten, ja das wären ja gar keine richtigen Computer, wenn wenn's halt richtige Computer wäre, dann könnte man damit ja als Schach spielen.
Ja, woraufhin dann hier irgendwie Andreas und Konsorten vom Club irgendwie losmarschiert sind und dann halt einfach mal einen Schach äh Programm auf dem Rechner installiert haben.
Ähm und dann äh wurde dann aber auch nochmal die Webseite von dieser Firma irgendwie auseinandergenommen und äh äh gehackt.
Da wurde dann mal soeben die komplette Liste der Techniker abgezogen ja mit all ihren IDs irgendwie so drei Buchstaben mit
drei Zahlen irgendwie
Pins und so ein Kram und so ganz nebenbei auch noch die ganzen private Keys dieser TLS-Verschlüsselung, mit dem diese Computer nämlich dann später diese Wahlergebnisse an dem Zentrale ablieferten.
Das heißt sozusagen die identifizierenden Schlüsselmerkmale, mit denen man Wahlergebnisse beim Hauptcomputer äh abliefert, ich vermute mal über Internet
Äh
die waren irgendwie verfügbar und der ganze Zugriff war auch nur über HTP, also die haben sich dann irgendwie äh an der Stelle noch nicht mal die Mühe gemacht, irgendwas äh ausschließlich über HTPS zu schützen
ein totales Drama. Und dann gab's irgendwie ja wurde dieser MSA das mal so vorgehalten und was denn damit so wäre und so, dann haben die halt keine Antwort drauf gegeben.
Also ist das Ganze an die Medien gegangen, wurde jetzt irgendwie eine große äh Geschichte und der Typ, der das äh,
sozusagen an die Medien getragen hat, beziehungsweise auch vorher versucht hat, die MSA davon zu äh unterrichten, dessen Haus wurde jetzt gestürmt und äh natürlich durchsucht und alle Computer äh konfisziert und das, obwohl er noch nicht mal zu den Leuten gehört, die diesen
offiziellen Report über diese ganzen äh Sicherheitslücken äh mit unterschrieben haben,
Ja, also gleich wieder so shoot the Messenger, äh mäßig geht es da äh äh ab gerade in Argentinien und das ganze System steigt
zeigt einfach ein vollkommenes Unverständnis für diese Problemlage, die wir hier in Europa schon mehrfach äh durch äh dekliniert haben.
Also man muss einfach verstehen, dass einfach mit Wahlcomputern eigentlich gar nichts erreicht werden kann. Also erstmal, nichts wird besser dadurch.
Also man hat ein es gibt ein Wahlsystem, das ist überprüfbar, das funktioniert, das skaliert und das ist einfach Proven, To be working.
Wenn man dann irgendwie Computer mit reinnimmt, riskiert man aber einfach, dass im Prinzip alle,
einer Wahl, dadurch nachhaltig gefährdet sind. Ja, also sowohl,
dass sie äh geheim sind, weil einfach zu viele Informationen äh in dem ganzen Prozess von den einzelnen Personen äh,
gesammelt werden. Das Geheimnis der Wahl ist äh unmittelbar unter in Gefahr. Damit natürlich auch verbunden die Freiheit äh der,
der Wahl und ähm all das,
Das ist halt einfach, also man gewinnt halt einfach genau überhaupt nichts. Man,
fängt sich einfach unheimliche Kosten auch ein, weil wenn man's wirklich sicher machen wollen würde, dann äh funktioniert das halt auch nicht wirklich. Und ist halt super teuer.
Ja und am Ende gewinnt man halt auch nicht viel dabei.
Okay und der gute Mann hat Sicherheitslücken gefunden, wollte äh
diese Bugs äh denen erklären, äh er hat keine Antwort bekommen, die einfach nur ihre Server abgeschaltet und dann äh als nächstes sind's bei ihm eingeritten, ja. Äh
da muss man natürlich auch nochmal sagen so letztendlich, ja, jemand, der ähm.
Der ein Sicherheitssystem hackt und den Hersteller darüber informiert äh und dann im nächsten Schritt unter Umständen die Öffentlichkeit darüber informiert, das ist
jemand von den Guten, der hätte ja auch einfach äh zu der Partei seiner Wahl oder zur meist bietenden Partei gehen können und sagen können, ey,
Vor der nächste Wahl gewinnen so, ne? Das äh wäre halt die, das ist halt die andere Seite, ja, also der derjenige, der es verkackt hat, äh äh diejenigen, die es verkackt haben, sind die, die die Software von den Wahlcomputern äh Scheiße geschrieben haben und die TLS-Zertifikate in ins Wape gelegt haben
und diejenigen, die die Dinger eingeführt haben, nicht derjenige, der sie sich angeschaut hat und ähm Sicherheitslücken darin gefunden hat. Das ist so ein häufiges Missverständnis.
Genau und als das System eingeführt wurde, hat angeblich einer Universität einen Sicherheitscheck gemacht und nichts gefunden. Ja, also,
wundert mich äh auch nicht. Jetzt allerdings, wo der offen ist und wo äh ich weiß nicht genau, welche Grad an Zugänglichkeit sieht, also ob irgendjemand schon mal so einen Rechner auch selber irgendwie in die Hand bekommen hat oder ob sie das nur vor Ort ausprobiert haben, aber es wird auch
berichtet, äh dass es wohl auch gelungen sei,
diese RFID-Balletts einfach durch äh ja ein Android-Telefon zu ersetzen. Also man konnte sozusagen sich gegenüber diesem Computer auch einfach äh als gültiger Wähler äh identifizieren und sagen, hier ich habe,
Ich habe hier noch ein gültiges Ballet, was aber sozusagen nur ein simuliertes Ballett war von einem Android-Telefon, was man dabei hatte. Und äh konnte damit eben auch mehrfach,
abstimmen.
Okay, also ein vollständig kaputtes System, was sowieso schon vom Design her ohnehin kaputt ist.
Genau, also was einfach komplett im Eimer ist und auch wieder zeigt, dass das auch einfach in der Gesellschaft nicht die entsprechenden äh ähm ja, richtigen Reaktionen gezeigt wird. Ich meine, das war ja auch in USA, ähnlich, in Indien gibt's halt auch immer sehr viel äh Repressionen auf die Leute, die die
ähm Probleme mit diesen Systemen äh gezeigt haben. Das Schwierige ist halt einfach, dass dass viele äh in diesen Entscheider,
sich schlicht irgendwie überhaupt nicht vorstellen können, dass es sich hierbei um einen generell unlösbares Problem handelt. Das das ist hier einfach ähm und ich habe das auch gemerkt in den in den Debatten,
Wir werden das jetzt sicherlich auch hier bei uns in den Kommentaren in den Kommentaren zu dieser Sendung auch wieder einfangen,
auch so im Open Saurslager, ja? Da gibt's dann auch schnell so diese Leute, so, ja, wenn das alles Open Source wäre, ja? Kann ich auch gleich sagen, könnt ihr einfach komplett,
backen. Open Source führt hier einfach zu Nischt
weil man kann so viel wie man will und auf U-Bahn zum durchforsten, äh da hinlegen und was nicht alles. Das Problem ist nicht, was irgendwo dokumentiert ist, was vielleicht unter Umständen auf diesen Computern läuft
Das Problem ist die Software, die konkret in dem Moment tatsächlich auf diesen Computer läuft. Und.
Man kann da noch so ein gut äh orchestriertes System haben. Man hat auf jeden Fall einen ganz neuen Angriffsvektor,
den zu vorher noch nicht gab, nämlich die Leute, die diese Systeme aufsetzen. Und während es früher,
eben kaum Hebel gegeben hat, wo man sagen kann, ich attackiere jetzt dieses Wahl
System grundsätzlich und versuche äh es in irgendeiner Form in eine andere Richtung zu schwingen. Also ich meine, okay, wir haben natürlich immer noch dieses diese Situation, Diktatur, autoritäres System
ja? Wo Wahlen sozusagen so als Feigenblatt-Ding durchgeführt werden. Da sind natürlich diese
ähm sind natürlich diese Bedingungen gegeben, dass man einfach auf großer Fläche Druck ausüben kann. Aber das ist, sagen wir mal, auch an sich erstmal kein freies System
oder helfen Computer auch im Übrigen kein Stück weiter, sondern machen das eigentlich alles noch viel schlimmer. Aber auch in einer freien.
Offenen Gesellschaft, wie wir das eben hier noch weitgehend haben.
Würden Computer eben einen neuen Angriffsvektor schaffen, nämlich die Leute, die tatsächlich in diesem technischen Zugriff sind und die diese Systeme eben tatsächlich herstellen, beliefern, installieren et cetera. Die nehme ich auf einmal nicht nur lokal an einer einzigen Stelle
sondern eben Weitflächig verteilt über alle Systeme hinweg in der Lage sind, diese Systeme zu beeinflussen. Und wenn da halt.
Taten wir aber schon, Tim.
Hatten wir, na ja, ich meine, was ich äh meine ist, in dem Moment, wo man halt jetzt Druck ausübt auf diese Leute,
Ja und sagt hier irgendwie äh schöne Familie haben sie da. Wäre doch schade, äh wenn denen was äh zustoßen würde. Dann äh schafft man sich einfach äh ganz neue Angriffsvektoren, die man so eben bisher noch überhaupt nicht hatte.
Und keinen einzigen Vorteil. Nur Nachteile, es kann nicht funktionieren und noch ein paar Nachteile dazu. Und keinen einzigen Vorteil, außer wenn man mal Wahlen manipulieren möchte oder äh auf Wahlhelfer verzichten möchte.
Ja und vor allem, man verliert auch noch etwas, also selbst, wenn alle Computer,
Also angenommen, alle Leute, die an diesem System beteiligt sind, sind erstens mal die totalen Security-Götter,
Leben irgendwie Demokratie und Freiheit bis irgendwie ins reinste Mark, sind geradezu göttlich davon erfüllt und würden auch niemals auch nur die Spur darüber nachdenken, irgendwas falsch zu machen.
Jeglicher Hardware, die geliefert wird. Jede CPU, die hier zum Einsatz kommt, ist komplett fehlerfrei, ja? Jeder Code, der geschrieben wird, ist komplett fehlerfrei, wie wir ja wissen, ist das ja sehr häufig äh der Fall, ja? Angenommen, all das wäre so.
Immer noch ein anderes Problem. Selbst wenn es perfekt funktionieren würde. Ich erinnere mich noch an so eine krass Radiosendung zu dem Thema. Und dann hatten wir,
Leute gebeten, da waren nämlich lief nämlich grad eine Wahl, wo diese Wahlcomputer nämlich auch zum Einsatz kamen. Da haben wir irgendwie Leute gebeten
sie doch bitte anrufen, wenn sie an einem Wahllokal dabei gewesen sind,
was sind ihre Erfahrungen sind? Und dann riefen halt erst so ein paar Leute an, so ja, hier bei uns wurde mit Papier gewählt, wie immer und wir so, na ja, und hat so das Gefühl, dass hier irgendwie äh,
Das ist alles mit rechten Dingen abging,
So, ja, ja, das das war irgendwie alles okay, ja und und was was macht dich da so sicher? Na ja, ich habe das ja alles gesehen und das, das, das war ja alles total klar. Und bist dir da wirklich total sicher, dass da die, ja, ich bin mir da total sicher,
Dann rief noch so zwei, drei Leute äh dieser Art an, immer dieselben Aussagen. Und dann rief einer an und meint so, ja bei uns wird dieser Wahlcomputer gemacht. Ja und war das alles okay? Ja, machte so den Eindruck,
So, ja und und,
bis sie dir da auch äh äh sicher, dass das irgendwie äh alles mit rechten Dingen zugegangen ist. Und dann kam halt so die Zweifel. Da kam so dieses.
Ja, ich nehme doch an, dass das okay ist. Ja
Ich kann ja nur davon ausgehen, dass die Maschine schon das Richtige getan hat, weil äh man hat ja keine einzige
keinen einzigen Zettel gesehen. Da da wurde am Schluss auf so einen Knopf gedrückt und da stand das Ergebnis auf dem Display und das Ergebnis des Displays, das wurde dann eben zur Kenntnis genommen.
Gab es dann das schöne Bild des CCC von zwei Wahlcomputern, die absolut identisch aussahen unter dem einen stand, das ist ein Wahlcomputer und das ist ein
manipulierter Wahlcomputer.
Ja, also das man kann eben die Manipulation nicht erkennen und die äh Möglichkeiten der Manipulation sind mannigfach. Aber ich glaube, das haben wir jetzt auch äh.
Ausreichend gewürdigt, genau.
Gewürdigt.
Eine Hinweis.
Würde mich trotzdem viel lieber darauf konzentrieren, dass ein Wahlcomputer den den einfachen Grundsatzanforderungen eine an eine Wahl nicht gerecht wird und dann spart man sich das ganze debattieren über wie der irgendwie manipuliert werden könnte oder nicht. Aber OK
Wir haben das Thema auf jeden Fall jetzt äh,
ausreichend behandelt, wenn euch irgendwo einer mit dem Wahlcomputer kommt, äh rennt weg. Jetzt müssen wir an der Stelle aber noch kurz äh anmerken.
Ich will noch eine Sendung, ich will nur mal kurz eine Sendung äh pluggen, die auch diese ganze grundsätzliche Theorie nochmal sehr schön in den Vordergrund stellt. Ich habe im CRE,
Zeit mich mit äh Ulrich Wiesner unterhalten,
Das ist derjenige, der gemeinsam mit seinem Vater vom Verfassungsgericht erfolgreich gegen Ballcomputer geklagt hat in Deutschland, was er dann zum Verbot der Wahlcomputer zumindest in der Form, wie sie bis dahin existierten, geführt hat. CAE hundertachtzehn, das Beicomputerurteil sehr äh,
würdige Sendung sich das nochmal anzuschauen. Da wird das alles wunderbar zusammengefasst. Jetzt darfst du nochmal was sagen.
Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr. Ähm letztes Thema für heute, ganz kurz, es gibt wir hatten ja jetzt viele ah doch Hacking Team war ja eigentlich auch eine gute Nachricht.
Wir haben noch eine, wir haben noch eine gute Nachricht. Mit vierhundertfünfundvierzig Jahr bei sechsund bei fünfundsechzig Neinstimmen.
Und zweiunddreißig Enthaltungen wurde eine Kompromissversion des Räderberichts vom,
EU-Parlament verabschiedet. Der Räderbericht ist also der diese äh.
Entschließung oder dieser dieser äh Report der Meinungsfindung des EU-Parlamentes eine Willensbekundung des EU Parlamentes
gemischt mit einer Tatsachenfeststellung in diesem Fall formuliert von der einzigen,
Pirate, Piratenabgeordneten in in Europaparlament. Julia Re.
Deutschen, sondern überhaupt der einzigen.
Sind die Schweden da auch nicht mehr drin, keiner mehr.
Nee, die sind rausgeflogen.
Einzigen Piratenabgeordneten im Europaparlament genau, Mitglied der Grünen-Fraktion dort. Äh die Julia hat sich da, glaube ich, jetzt in den letzten, weiß, seit wann ist sie da jetzt, ist seit zwei Jahre her die Wahl, oder?
Seit sie da drin ist,
sehr äh ausführlich mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt, hat auch auf der äh Republika zu dem Thema gesprochen. Also sie hat echt mal so Urheberrecht mit allen Nords und Ungleichmäßigkeiten und Widersprüchen,
bis ins Detail studiert und quasi in,
Wir erinnern uns, EU ist ja immer äh vereinheitlichung der Märkte, ne.
Harmonisierung.
Harmonisierung der Märkte und im Rahmen dieser Hormonisierung will sich die eben jetzt auch ein einmonetarisiertes Urheberrecht geben.
Monetarisiert.
Ein haarmonetarisiertes Urheberrecht möchte die EU sich geben. Und da ist eben jetzt äh ihr Report, der äh ihr Bericht, der erste Aufschlag zu. Ähm.
Und ähm bis, wie das so ist bei solchen Berichten, ne. Also wir erinnern uns, das war ja auch zum Beispiel bei der bei
Neutralität und beim Datenschutz, sodass wir das auch hatten, ja? Da haben wir auch dann immer drüber gesprochen. Jetzt war eben mal Urheberrecht dran. Auch wieder äh jemand, der da wahrscheinlich sich das eine oder andere graue Haar und das ein oder andere Magengeschwür in der ganzen Nummer geholt hat. Vielen Dank für diesen Einsatz, Julia. Die ähm,
Bis zuletzt äh wird das natürlich wild diskutiert, ne? Und dann stürmen da die Lobbyisten auf die Parlamente ein und so und äh wollen wollen die entstehenden Feuer mit großen Schuhen austreten. Ähm
Zuletzt war dann noch ein Angriff auf die Panoramafreiheit diskutiert worden, also äh die die,
Recht, dass man halt einfach im öffentlichen Raum auch mal fotografieren kann, insbesondere dann äh äh sage ich mal besondere architektonische Bauten.
Da gab es dann auch eine eine große äh äh Aktion der Wikipedia äh Editoren und Fotografen. Dann gab's.
Berichtete.
Genau, dann gab's in der letzten Minute kroch dann noch wieder so ein Unionsabgeordneter aus seinem äh aus seiner Kokshöhle und äh warf da so ein Leistungsschutzrecht mit rein und wollte irgendwie,
äh
dass das Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverleger jetzt auch auf EU-Ebene einführen. Das wurde beides erfolgreich abge ähm,
abgewehrt und jetzt eben der Räderbericht mit einigen Kompromissen, aber ein durchaus.
Progressiver Bericht äh des Urheberrechtes, der ähm vor allem auch die Nutzer mit einem äh mit Rechten ausstatten möchte. Das ist also der äh der Teil, auf den äh Julia sich da auch sehr.
Vorbildlich immer fokussiert hat, dass sie sagt,
Diese ganzen Urheberrechte, die gibt's eigentlich überall, ja, also jeder und die sind immer einfach nur gegen den Nutzer, ja? Und auch einfach mal zu sagen, okay, wir wollen.
Auch mal mini, wir wollen einfach auch mal Rechte haben, welche Rechte hat denn der Nutzer noch, ja? Können wir zum Beispiel mal darüber reden, dass äh dass es ein Verleihrecht äh für E-Books
im wissenschaftlichen Bereich oder so, ja? Dann äh eine ein Nischenthema äh,
wo ich jetzt gar nicht weiß, ob es in dem Report so äh.
Mit drin steht, aber da gab's ja so bei den es gibt ja so immer wieder dieses Thema den den digitalen,
ähm äh das das digitale Erbe, ne. Was ist eigentlich mit deinen digitalen Anschaffungen.
Äh wenn wenn du äh wenn du irgendwie dann,
äh von uns gehst, ja, kannst du das vererben, kannst du diese Nutzungsrechte vererben oder nicht? Das sind ja alles Fragen, die irgendwie mal geklärt werden müssen. Und
insgesamt überhaupt mal den den Nutzer äh oder die Nutzerin dort mit mit Rechten auszustatten, ist natürlich äh eine äh ein notwendiger Schritt.
Und äh Julia schreibt also selber darüber zu über diesen Bericht, den ich jetzt nur in Zusammenfassung äh gelesen habe, dass sie mit diesem
Kompromiss zufrieden ist und sich freut, dass das dass das Parlament diese Position eingenommen hat.
Ähm das war auch ein ein dickes Brett, was sie da mit einem dünnen Bohrer behandeln musste. Ähm.
Weil sie eben auch immer wieder mit dem mit dem Unverständnis der digitalen Welt unter ihren Kollegen konfrontiert wurde. Ähm,
Jetzt kann man natürlich diese, diesem ganzen Thema nur viel Erfolg im weiteren Verlauf wünschen, denn wir wissen ja, was äh mit solchen ähm,
Reports dann eben im weiteren Verlauf so
noch passieren kann, ne, wenn sie dann erstmal äh auf dem Schreibtisch äh von Oettinger landen, äh der dann da aber wieder eine ganz andere Meinung zu hat, ne. Eine achso, eine weitere Sache, die ich da sehr wichtig fanden, diesen Report, den mir
dieses Geoblocking, ne? Ähm.
Das fand ich sehr spannend, weil da haben sie argumentiert, über den Zugang für kulturelle Minderheiten.
Stell dir mal vor, du bist jetzt irgendwie so, du bist halt ein Expat, ja? Ne, du bist hast dein Land verlassen,
weil du in in Berlin-Mitte äh oder in Berlin Neukölln jetzt wohnen muss, weil das da so unglaublich aufregend ist. Ja und dann musst du aber natürlich trotzdem noch irgendwie,
äh deine deine US-Serien gucken, ne? Dann bist du ja quasi eine von der EU diskriminierte Minderheit.
Weil das Geoblocking äh dich daran hindert, äh an an der kulturellen Teilhabe deines äh deines äh Heimatlandes äh.
Wobei das Geoblocking an der Stelle jetzt nicht von der EU ausgeht, sondern primär von den USA und von den entsprechenden Rechte äh Vergebern ausgeht.
Genau und von der von der von der mangelnden Harmonisierung des äh europäischen Binnenmarktes, ne? Denn es ist gibt's ja nicht nur interkontinental, sondern auch innereuropäisch. Also.
Der mangelnden, harmonenden Monetisierung.
Harmonie,
Okay, also Glückwunsch an Julia an dieser Stelle und wir werden das Thema äh sicherlich dann in Zukunft weiter vertiefen, wenn wir diesen Report jetzt äh auf dem Weg
durch die europäischen Mühlen hoffentlich zu einem erfolgreichen Ergebnis begleiten können.
Grauen.
Ich schließe mich dem an. Das ist auf jeden Fall äh auch bemerkenswert finde ich äh die Leistung. Ich meine, sie ist ja auch Newcomerin in dem äh Parlament. Da ist man ja auch erstmal gut damit beschäftigt, äh sich da überhaupt ähm durchzusetzen. Und äh überhaupt erstmal,
Zu verstehen, wie das wie das System an sich äh funktioniert, das hat sie sicherlich im Vorfeld schon alles ganz gut beobachtet, aber dann eben auch
tatsächlich diese äh Rolle zugespielt zu bekommen. Muss man jetzt mal sehen, was da draus bleibt. Wir sehen ja bei der Netzneutralität, dass jetzt nur ein ähm vom Parlament angenommenes äh Beschluss
hier noch lange nicht in der Lage ist, auch die
drei Jahr Dialoge zwischen europäischem Rat und Kommission und Parlament zu überleben. Von daher muss man mal schauen, wie sehr das jetzt noch unter Beschuss äh liegt, aber ist natürlich grundsätzlich schon mal sehr schön zu sehen,
dass äh hier überhaupt Bewegung im Spiel ist und dass das Parlament auch in gewisser Hinsicht zeigt, dass eben ähm,
europäische Politik äh jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer bedrohlich sein muss, sondern es ist eben auch sehr davon abhängt, wie man sich dort äh einbringt,
ja, welche Hilfestellung man auch dem politischen Prozess dort äh gibt und am Ende vielleicht auch sogar, wie man da so hinwählt.
Und dann hat uns eine traurige Nachricht ereilt, nämlich die Nachricht über den Tod von Casperbauden.
Vielleicht manche von euch kennen vielleicht manche auch nicht,
So ein Superstar war er irgendwie nie, aber er ist äh den Leuten, die so im Bereich der Privatsphäre ähm.
Und äh entsprechenden Fragen äh unterwegs sind, schon schon immer ein Begriff gewesen, weil er irgendwie seit Ewigkeiten da äh Aktivist gewesen ist, auch sehr häufig auf dem Kongress gewesen ist, auch auf dem letzten Kongress im Übrigen.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du ihn äh persönlich kennengelernt.
Ja, da ich, also ich hatte, also ich hatte hauptsächlich schriftlich mit ihm natürlich zu tun bei seiner Talk-Einreichung zum einunddreißig C drei, wo er ja auch noch äh ein äh Talk gehalten hat, The Cloud Conspirity. Ähm.
Der war seit zweitausendzwei bei Microsoft als äh Datenschutz,
quasi und ist dann irgendwie, ich glaube, schief, privatvisor oder so was heißt das, äh für vier vierzig Länder geworden und so und er hatte quasi.
Microsoft ähm er wurde quasi bei Microsoft entlassen zweitausendelf, nachdem er,
ähm gegen diese ganze ähm äh im Prinzip gegen sie ist ganz safe harber und so äh.
Gewettert hat und letztendlich eigentlich das gesamte Wissen über Prison sich quasi schon aus öffentlichen Quellen und Zusammenhängen so zusammengeräumt hatte. Ähm.
Und äh dann hat er sich halt quasi auf insbesondere auf den Foren Intelligence Act äh gestürzt, eben als als Datenschutzbeauftragter und da eben drauf geblickt und hat gesagt, so okay
dass äh wenn du jetzt irgendwie deine wenn die Regierung jetzt irgendwie in diese Microsoft Cloud-Computing gehen, dann nach,
Foren Intelligence Act heißt das, dass da dass sie ihren ganzen Kram der NSA offen aufs Tablett liefern
ja? Das heißt, er hat diesen ganzen Kram schon vorhergesehen und das letztendlich sogar mit seiner ähm,
äh mit seiner äh Karriere bezahlt. Da die für diese
diese Recherche und und diese diese Überzeugung, für die er da eingetreten ist, der war
äh in den in den Jahren danach äh glaube ich nicht mehr irgendwie fest angestellt und hat eben in seiner hat halt als Vortragsredner noch irgendwie ab und zu irgendwo auftreten können, aber hatte aus äh,
gegebenen Anlass eben äh keine, soweit ich weiß, keine gute Stelle mehr als Datenschutzbeauftragter, weil sich natürlich keiner einen äh Datenschutzbeauftragten,
ins Haus holt, der besonders unbequem ist und genau liest, was da abgeht, ja.
Und er hat auch immer, also war auch ein, er war vom Charakter her nicht besonders einfacher Typ. Ähm und ähm ähm hat dann auch sehr äh,
Ja, hat auch immer betont, dass er halt diese ganze äh Snowden Sache hat, kommen, sehen und so. Und er war also nicht so ein besonders einfacher Typ. Also ich glaube beim äh beim.
Bei in anderen Kommunikationen mit ihm ist er dann auch mal irgendwie gerne mal äh bisschen ähm bisschen unter die Decke gegangen,
aber.
Verstehen. Ich meine noch.
Ein Mensch, der ein Mensch, der halt wirklich für Überzeugung äh eingetreten ist, für Überzeugung Opfer gebracht hat und äh.
Ja, ein herber Verlust ist.
Genau, Elsankrebs äh gestorben ist.
Ich kannte ihn nicht gut, aber ich kannte ihn auch noch so von früheren Kongressen, er war ja schon vor Ewigkeiten auch auf dem äh Kongress und auch schon zu Zeiten äh als Aktivist unterwegs, wo er noch nicht bei,
bei Microsoft war, also wer jetzt den Eindruck bekommen hat, äh,
wäre da sozusagen aus Microsoft heraus in diese Rolle äh hineingewachsen, dem es mitnichten äh so, sondern der ist schon
deutlich früher dort aktiv gewesen, ist schon so in den, in den neunziger Jahren bekannt gewesen, da hab ich ihn auch irgendwie mal auf 'n Kongress kennengelernt, paar Mal gesprochen, als nett
äh empfunden und insofern schade, dass er jetzt äh hat äh von uns gehen müssen und ihr könnt euch ja mal den letzten Vortrag auf dem einunddreißig C drei anschauen.
Mir dazu nicht ein. Das reicht jetzt wohl auch, oder? Volle Sendung.
Ja, dann bleibt äh an dieser Stelle ähm.
Der Tod von Casper Bauen zu bedauern und Matthias und einer unbekannten Person trotzdem zu danken, auch wenn sie das nicht verhindern konnten.
Jo ähm dann haben wir die Sendung äh schön in Überlänge.
Gebracht hier. Aber wir waren uns am Anfang schon einig, dass es äh durchaus da mal drauf hinauslaufen äh konnte, ob der Vielfalt der grundsätzlichen Thematiken, die hier wieder aufgerufen wurden.
Linus.
Ja, ich habe alles gesagt.
Sendung heißt nicht, dass man, dass man, dass man am Ende dann auch noch besonders äh aus.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob du Lovelay noch was zu Wahlcomputern sagen willst.
Nö. Du? Ich ich kann auch, ich kann auch ganz schön aus.
Alleine hier in diesem Podcast. Muss mich nur mal fragen.
Okay.
Supi, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, ciao ciao.